foreign
[Music]
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book clubs
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and make you more social
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
what is a chess Dynasty
unceasing dominance move after move
again and again and again we have a
recitation we have history he is the
five-time fide World chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time oh my
god did he just block yeah he did I'm
Blown Away the game is over
as the Chess World Turns to Kazakhstan
the Magnus Carlson Dynasty is set to
close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs
for two chess Superstars lying in weight
until next time is now
Jan napam Nashi has methodically done
what he needed to do to get another shot
at the title the pressure to seize the
moment this time rests heavily upon him
it's a draw the big missed opportunity
he feels it and wow I haven't seen Yan
like that after a game Robert I don't
know if that's a good signup
dingley red nose first hand with the end
of this dynasty means an unexpected
chance to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Fame dingly Wren held his
ground he has managed to strike back
twice he needs to do it one more time to
level the score
the legacy of this Championship spans
across centuries it reads from the names
of Chess Giants
for the first time in a decade a new
name will raise the trophy and be etched
into chess history
it's the 2023 feed a world championship
whose name will next be called champion
[Music]
it is the day after the rest day this is
picturesque Astana come on the outside
but it's going to get very stormy inside
the playing Arena of the Saint Regis
Hotel Yana Pharmacy and dingler and are
in an intense back and forth battle to
win the crown we are live inside the
playing Hall as we wait for the players
to arrive it's going to be an exciting
game 10. welcome everyone I'm your host
International Master Tanya sachdev
alongside Michael commentators
Grandmaster Robert Hess and Grandmaster
Fabiano caruana welcome guys
we had a fantastic game nine it was the
longest of this match so far Bobby how
was your rest day
it was good after such a long game I
think we all needed a rest day
especially I'm sure the players did and
I hope they come with Renewed Energy for
the last few games and I'm expecting
some creative ideas today
absolutely as are we Fabi we enter the
final five games of this world
championship match and I have to say I
missed the chess yesterday gotten so
used to it that they just did not feel
complete chat don't lie to yourself
don't lie to me you know you're equally
invested in this match Robert is it just
me or are you feeling the emotional
investment too how could anyone watching
it not feel the emotional investment
we've seen ding's emotions he laid them
out for everybody to witness and Jana
Pomchi he was quite upset after that
game nine performance where he felt like
he had the upper hand so yeah this has
been highly emotional I'm just excited
for the action to continue
it's gonna be a big game 10 because
there is so much at stake today and
we've had such an explosive world
championship match from the very start
the players have been trading blows
we've had five decisive games so far
starting from game two Yana Pharmacy
being the first to draw blood and tattoo
with the black pieces setting the tone
for the action that we were about to see
and with that win it was it was dingler
and who would
strike back and equalize the score we
saw four back-to-back victories with the
white pieces and they were halted to a
peaceful result in game 8 and game 9
ending in a draw game nine was a big
Marathon fight lasting over six hours 82
moves played Jana pomnushi ended with a
draw we could see the frustration and a
missed Opportunity by him that meant
that we finish go into game 10 with Yan
leading with a point he's at five ding
is at four Jan is two and a half points
away from being a crown world champion
but ding's task is cut he needs to
equalize the match and game nine Fabi
was a close call for Deng
and that we saw
it ending in a draw but then we could
see
a very angry napomnishi that was a bit
surprising because we haven't seen that
expression from Yan before that even in
the press conference uh it was clear
that things were not had not gone Yan's
away tabi were you surprised with the
end of that game
I was surprised that he showed so much
disappointment but it might have been
because although we saw the evaluation
never swung so much that Jan was at any
point winning in the game he might have
felt really really close not only to the
game Victory but maybe in his mind to
what would have been the match Victory
if he had won that game because as as we
were seen in the statistics uh the odds
for each player if he had won he would
have had enormous chances to to take
home the entire match I mean it would
have been such a hill for dink to climb
back while a one game spread still feels
like you know we've seen that already
before in this match that's not like the
true Breakaway point when it's already
feeling like one player is running away
with the match so maybe Jan felt like
that was his moment to strike
yeah I mean a win for Jana Pomchi would
have been huge for his winning chances
of the overall a world title but for
dingley Ren he held his ground so he was
pretty happy it seemed in the post-game
conference he now gets three whites in
the last five games so I do think the
emotions will continue to swing back and
forth but I think ding sort of won the
Battle of game nine even though the game
was a draw
never definitely looked disappointed
after that one and I'll have to ask you
Robert what are you expecting him how
would he overcome that in that rest day
what are you expecting from Nepal apart
from that pink shirt I actually think
he'll go away from the salmon color
shirt today it didn't work out for him
in game nine when he had the upper hand
and couldn't convert it so I think that
we can expect Jan to change his attire
we can expect dingley Ren to play
something new he has Richard report as
his second when you hire that man you
have to play variety because variety is
the spice of life and I think we are
going to get something new today
yeah it's hard to predict anything from
this match but the one thing that we can
guarantee is that it is going to be an
action-packed game 10 and we've got Mike
on the ground with the inside story from
Astana
thanks guys round nine produced yet
another draw but not before some heavy
middle game excitement Grandmaster ding
Loren shows yet another opening to
defend as black but quickly found his
King under heavy pressure he was able to
find a way to liquidate into an end game
where he was only down a pond but he had
to prove that that defense would hold
over about six hours of play it was
actually much more difficult than he
thought and here's what ding had to say
after the game was over first I thought
it was a easy draw but I realized it's
not so simple especially after the
position he played King F4 if I go night
the E4 it might lost because this 396
King E5 and he had many waiting moves
here this match continues to enthrall
the public with noted chess luminaries
like Gotham chess saying that at various
points they were even yelling at the
screen I wanted to know has Jan
napomnishi ever gotten so invested in a
match emotionally that he yelled at his
computer screen and he had quite a funny
answer he here's what Yan had to say I
guess like every online tournament like
doesn't matter if I play or if I follow
I'm constantly yelling something yeah
constantly cursing and uh and so on yes
[Music]
yeah it's quite nice that people are
yeah
find the classical chess and the match
so exciting
so here we find ourselves only five
games left but ding has an additional
white in his pocket he's gonna need it
down a point what will happen in round
10 in this most unpredictable of World
Championships it's going to be a fun
race to the finish for chess.com this is
Mike Klein inside the playing Hall in
Astana Kazakhstan
big game 10 coming up and a
DN these are the odds by our chesscom
stats team depending on the result of
this game how much of a favorite is Jana
pamushi to be the 17th Chess World
Champion well he starts with the black
today ding is going to be white but if
Yan wins today the 97 favorite to become
world champion in case of a draw it
gives them about an 83 margin and if
ding for the third time in this match
does Strike Back today with the white
pieces the match is wide open it's
anyone's match just a 51.5 or there for
Yan Robert how critical is this how much
of a must-win game is this for ding I
think to the viewers you may think he
has to win he has to tie the score but
he has three total white games remaining
the one today and then two more going
forward so you cannot be all in at this
juncture if you were to lose today that
would be devastating to your chances he
still will have more opportunities down
the stretch he needs to play something
sharp he needs to get his chances but he
should not try to go all in
yeah I feel like this is not yet an
all-in game not a game that he
absolutely has to win but he's starting
to feel the pressure with the few games
remaining in the match and the pressure
is starting to build up more and more
that I'm I'm still behind and you know
I've had so many chances with the white
pieces and I've I've taken some some of
those chances but chances don't come
that often against the player as strong
as young and especially you know when
he's so well prepared and you've already
shown your intentions and you've had
some ideas
you know he'll he'll be feeling the
pressure to create something especially
in the opening and in these remaining
White games
and that pressure only builds with each
and every passing game the good news for
doing fans is that out of the final five
games thing will start with three whites
today being one of them and he needs to
find a way to take risks to create
chances to try to get something with the
white pieces but he can't afford to push
too much a loss would be an absolute
disaster and in these kind of situations
it's so easy for excessive risk to
backfire thing learning today in game 10
is walking a tightrope it's a big moment
and it all comes down to the start of
the opening we've seen ding come up with
Incredible surprises throughout the
match that has been one of the most
unique factors of this world
championship very uncharacteristic of
the kind of Chess that we usually see at
this big stage take a look at that every
single game starting from game one we've
been treated to an opening surprise to
an unexpected thought and notice how
certain openings they are including game
aim for biding the English game six
we've got the London here then ding with
the black pieces playing the French and
game eight nimso Indian what we saw
where he nearly equalized the Mad score
and then in that big game nine he played
this idea in the Berlin with Bishop C5
and apart from dealing with what he
needs to come up with with the white
pieces there is also the whole drama
around the potential leak of the
training games and the opening prep
Hikaru said that this is an
unprecedented prep League he's convinced
that there's no way that these aren't
training games between Ding lyron and
Richard rappo Robert would you agree
yeah I think at this point we'd all be
lying to ourselves if we thought there
was anything but the actual preparation
of dingly red and Richard report that
said uh Fabi you mentioned this the
other day he doesn't think it's the
biggest deal in the world uh Richard
report is somebody with probably way
more up his sleeve in terms of
adventurous play and dingley ren is a
superstar and has been for about the
last decade so I don't think that the
players need to be overly concerned with
a preparation League I do think that
we're going to see a new opening today
because that's just been the flavor of
the match and I think that for yonda
palmisi he gets to the board early he's
going to have to sit and think hard
about what his choices will be because
he doesn't know what is coming his way
yeah the funny thing is that one of
those accounts that was playing those
games went online publicly and said I am
not seeingly right and this is not
Richard report
and I don't know if that's it feels like
we're already in like poker territories
like the duff the bluff and the Double
Bluff here and
um but yeah it's it's definitely an
interesting Wrinkle in the match and we
did see that the Berlin was played which
was also played in some of those
training games or some of those games
played online so it's hard to tell
exactly what's going on I I do think
that some of the openings shown in those
games were already played in the match
so a lot of that information is already
out there it's not uh it's no longer
really Elite because it's already been
played
and there's like one last remaining
opening idea which is the reverse
Sicilian with Queen C2 but I don't
expect to see that in the game today I
do think a reverse Sicilian could easily
be played just because it's a rich
direction to get a fight
but I'm hoping I'm kind of hoping for
another nimzo that was such an exciting
game that we got and uh in in that game
eight just so unpredictable I'm hoping
to see another game like that where we
we have no idea what's gonna happen both
players potentially winning the game
that's the kind of fight we want to see
yeah absolutely and that's the kind of
fight that we are being treated to in
this world championship match you
mentioned Fabi you want to see another
nimzo and that brilliant idea of Rook A2
which created such a dangerous position
in the middle game for Jana pamelishi
was indeed one of the games that was
tried in the training games that we saw
between these two then the bishop C5 of
the Berlin and right now what we have
are the live scenes from the playing
Arena we see Empty Chairs but the
players indeed have arrived in their
resting area they will in just a few
moments be stepping out into this Glass
Room of the Saint Regis Hotel we see
there David yada he is an official from
fide we are about to stop the action
Tabby you mentioned a reverse Sicilian
possibility uh is that an expectation
towards things starting with one C4 and
Jan replying with the kingspawn move E5
is that the opening that you're talking
about well we've already seen uh one of
the variations of the reverse Sicilian
we've seen that ding definitely has this
has a potential weapon against Yan and
he's also played against him in the
candidates albeit on it successfully and
successfully in the 2019 Grand chest
towards a grab event so this is
definitely a battle been a Battleground
for the players I I think it could
definitely be a continuation of their
theoretical flight today but what I'm
really hoping for is a nimso with the
fourth move A3 known as the zanish
variation it's similar to what ding
played in game eight but rather
different so some similar ideas uh it
feels like the team the ding team with
Richard and and whoever else is working
there is definitely looking in that
direction but it's hard to predict I
mean ding has been uh the definition of
unpredictable in this match so far
uh the one thing that's been predictable
as we see the players that are shaking
hands uh the only time that you'll see
them perhaps share just the tiniest of
smiles is that yahan indeed is back with
the pink shirt these are two incredible
Fighters with very different playing
Styles extremely different personalities
and matched in strength thing they're
starting with the white pieces humble
kind he has that Persona of that
hulk-like atmosphere when he sits on the
board the beast in him comes out on the
other side his antagonist with the black
pieces
he has been asserting domination he has
been asserting his powerful presence on
the board and of it as well this is a
battle that is done for the ages Robert
what are you making of this how
confident is ding feeling today with
white well my first guess was already
incorrect I said he would not wear the
same culture but I think perhaps as long
as he continues to lead the match he'll
keep that shirt uh available and for
ding I mean you see him sipping on the
water he's getting ready I I think the
last couple games in some ways have been
good for him I mean he lost game seven
in heartbreaking Fashion After out
playing janapamshi then in game eight he
had the upper hand he let that slip game
nine he was worse but he held so I feel
like he's just getting back into the
flow of the chest after what was it
really just really backbreaking moment
of game seven it could have allowed him
to go astray and continue a losing
streak but no he was able to right the
ship he is now just in any other day of
Chess except it's the world championship
stage but I think for dingley Ren I mean
he should be feeling pretty good overall
he has good chances he's been putting
pressure on Jan when he's had the white
pieces
see the jackets are
off in just a few seconds and we've been
talking about Jana pamushi and him
returning with the pink shot as long as
he maintains the lead Robert is that a
little Superstition there we know that
chess players are known to be a little
superstitious uh safe to say that Yan
feels comfortable and maybe slightly
that this is his lucky shot well just
like Stevie Wonder sings they're very
superstitious writings on the wall and
it's the writing of the world
championship so when things are going
right you want to keep them that way so
I'm not too surprised by Jana palmshi
one of the best chess players in the
world of all time keeping the status quo
he wants that to remain so yeah chess
players are superstitious Jan has shown
that in the past so I'm not too
surprised even though I predicted he
would change it
I think it was vishwanathan on and a
legend
going Yahweh do not change what you've
been doing and that we see the special
guest the chief guest about to make the
first move on the board the inaugural
move and ding will of course big fat
pack and then we will see what is his
preparation what was the move that was
played E4
that's not something that we've seen
from ding any chances of that actually
happening on move one today
there are chances but I don't know I
mean it looked like he was saying
something to her so was he saying play
E4 is that he he was saying
uh so there's you're saying there's a
chance
I'm saying there's a chance but he's
thinking no no way
I'm gonna drop it on this I think one
safe
so if you're gonna see in English and
there it is 1c4 played he was thinking
about it or at least he was trying to
make us think he was thinking about it
yeah I think he's playing mind games
fubby and I guess how important is that
when you're the chess that's all gonna
have to be played over the board but do
you think he's using psychology to kind
of get back at you
well we we saw him think also before
playing Knight F6 the Berlin variation
the day before
or the game before I should say so he
does seem to be I don't know if he
thinks it causes some anxiety in your
opponent it can actually be the case
that people feel some anxiety because
there's some variations you're scared to
see some variations you're more happy to
see just based on your level of uh
preparedness
and sometimes you want to like induce
that anxiety by just you know waiting a
moment putting all those thoughts in
your opponent's head
oh we're seeing an interesting variation
so I didn't expect this one although
it's a good fighting choice
and Okay so
the basically the two branches in this
variation after E4 or black can put the
bishop on C5 or the bishop on B4 and the
bishop on B4 is a very positional line
and the big one C5 is a very sharp line
because white is pretty much should take
on E5
take only five D4
and black plays Bishop to B4 after
white takes 25 and black takes on e4
all happening so I don't even have to
draw the arrow so just let the players
do this thing here and well it's a sharp
line for sure that's good news for
dingley Ren right but how forcing is it
so it's on super 4C but there's an idea
for white here and I think we'll see it
on the board it starts with queen F3
black takes on C3
white takes back with the pawn black
usually plays Bishop to A5 although it's
not obligatory
and then White Castles long
and the idea was actually first played
against Me by Magnus Carlson in the 2019
uh Grand Swiss event
I think he'll play Bishop to a or Bishop
to C5
that's a rare move okay so he's avoiding
uh he's avoiding that long Castle stuff
that that could potentially happen
and I don't know this move
but it's not good news for ding if he
doesn't know it because if he doesn't
know it it's very unlikely he'll be able
to prove an advantage here I mean queen
G3 looks critical
absolutely critical
Fabi because I
deciding and I have the database in
front of me are going to
intermission with about 70 plus games
but Bishop C5 has been played 40 plus
times in this position so it is the
second most popular move after which
Bishop E7 is also a move that has to be
considered ding he does slow down
definitely was expecting Bishop A5 but
it would be surprising if after this
main this sort of back and forth in the
opening with the pawns being traded in
the structure he slows down for too long
on Bishop C5 and as you said Queen G3 it
is indeed the response that has happened
most number of times it hits the G7 Pawn
you are playing it with the tempo black
looks like he doesn't have time to go
shot castle with the bishop jumping into
8-6 threatening a mate and one that
could be a very dangerous threat because
you don't have to move G6 where you lose
the rook and I see if Notch and that
would be a disaster for yes Fabi this
was my question is this really so bad
because I there are sometimes cases
where you can sacrifice The Exchange in
this matter you play probably Queen
takes f8
and yeah it's it's a it's a exchange for
sure normally you shouldn't do this for
anyone
you know tempted in the chat to start
sacrificing their Rooks left and right
usually it's not a good idea but
sometimes the bishop especially a strong
one like on C
ycle maybe bishop takes a faith followed
by Bishop G7 Queen E7 and a quick attack
on that e-pawn
I don't know what the idea is after
Queen G3 because if not for Castle
I guess you you can
you can play G6
but it'll invites Bishop to G5
then you're forced to play Bishop B7 and
I'm not sure that this is exactly what
you want
white shank in my head you know I'm
looking at this position Fabi I think
you're just think white just has so much
more activity in this
yeah and white can also play H4 here or
maybe you know it's it's definitely a
tempting option
so
I don't know what the uh but the thing
is like Jana's prepared so whatever he
has in mind it's probably pretty pretty
decent what about kids sorry to cut you
off there Fabi but I was just thinking
but the last World Championship where
against Magnus uh Jan king of eight
voluntarily here it makes more sense
because it protects G7 doesn't
compromise your Pawn structure is this
terrible losing your right to Castle or
is it okay I I think it's very logical
so it looks like white can continue with
development maybe bishop to E2 is is a
fair move
and if D6 I probably want to play Bishop
to F or maybe bishop to G5 immediately
but I'm not sure maybe bishop F4 is a
more natural way
because I want to be able to take only
five with the bishop I don't think black
should be taking that pawn at the moment
and yeah ding ding is rather surprised
by this
so in that game between uh Magnus and
Young from from the last World
Championship
he followed it king of Ved up with H5
right that was the the whole point of it
and I can also see a H5 happening at
some point in this position
you're brave if you're on the palms you
plays like this I mean it comes very
unexpectedly to me Tanya I we thought
that he has a half Point uh point lead
excuse me every half point is good for
him playing in this style you kidding me
I love it Robert I love the position
that we already have and yeah she makes
the move Bishop C5 leaves the board
thing in his first think of a game 10.
and I want to also highlight Robert the
difference between Bishop C5 and the
move that Fabi earlier mentioned with
Bishop to E5 and why these ideas are not
equally strong for white if black chose
the retreating Square on A5 now imagine
if the bishop did step back to A5 and
you play Queen G3 again trying to
provoke Black's King to make a decision
as the G7 pawners attack in this case
that can actually go shot Castle shot
Castle becomes a real Choice without
having to lose material Bishop 86 is no
more a strong option for y because black
has the stunning Bishop C3 which
actually completely would tilt the game
in Black's favor if white picks up the
bishop it would mean that the 86 Bishop
Falls and
that is an absolutely fine position for
black doing well has castled has an
extra Pawn for compensation of that
destroyed Pawn structure E5 can come
under Fire but if you don't take that
Bishop on C3 you don't have a good
Square for the king wherever you move it
black will again go boom Bishop E5 and
manage to take everything in control we
see the valbar approve of this and this
would be a bad line for white to follow
with the move Bishop A5 which is why
that's the move of choice when faced
with this position Yan plays another
less popular move Bishop C5 which allows
this line simply because the C3 Pawn is
not attacked anymore Queen G3 would be a
strong response here
do you guys mind if I go on a bit of a
tangent in terms of the theory of this
variation I think everybody would love
nothing more Fabi go for it so if we go
back to that Bishop A5
and and Tanya you're absolutely correct
that Queen G3 is no longer such a
dangerous option A wise disposal
but there is this kind of Bishop to F4
developing move short Castle
and
I kind of thought this variation was
pretty decent for black back in the day
and then Magnus played long Castle
against me
and I I managed to survive but I
remember being in a complete panic in
this position
because it's scary when your opponent
classes long and you're like
it's it's obviously very anti-positional
to double your C pawns and put the King
on that side of the board on the other
hand white is going to play King to B2
at some point the king will protect the
see-through and then play Bishop D3 and
then attack with you know Queen G3 uh
Bishop H6 ideas Bishop G5 rookie one all
of White's Pieces come into the game
very quickly and you can't play D6
and so this position hasn't been played
a lot after that it's considered
sort of playable for black but also
super super dangerous
and I'm not at all surprised why Jan did
not want to go for this you know black
in desperation usually tries to break
open the B file playing like I think I
played Queen E7 King V2 and Rook to B8
uh just to get just to like play B5 and
try to bust things open before white
gets a devastating attack on the king
side because all of White's pieces are
aimed they're all blacks pieces are not
as much aimed in that direction so black
is not defending with as many pieces as
white as attacking and this is crazy
stuff
we're speechless here I mean this kind
of position is so wild black doesn't
have a single Pawn past the seventh rank
so it's a starting Square white has so
much extra space thanks to these pawns
that are sticking out the King on B2
looks like it's wide open but I guess
even the move B5 doesn't lead to a
Checkmate because this white Bishop on
F1 protects the square but yeah I would
not voluntarily walk into the line of
fire like Magnus Carlsen did against
ufabi but yeah great recall and uh maybe
Yonder Palm she's saying ding is
probably well prepared in this line but
as we see he hasn't responded to Bishop
C5 so question for you is considering
you're so well prepared and have played
in this variation before do you think he
actually hasn't looked at this or he's
just trying to remember his preparation
or he's trying to think what does yond
want from me what's his thought process
like
I think that he might not be familiar
with it and one of the reasons why is
because
at the top level most players have been
very hesitant to enter this variation
with black
and the simple reason why is because uh
after E4 if we go back to that moment
black has another option which for
example Hikaru played against me
recently Bishop to B4
and here white doesn't have any tactics
involving Knight takes E5 white needs to
defend the E4 Pawn so plays D3
black usually plays D6
white kicks in Bishop away with A3 the
bishop does not want to give itself away
for the Knight on C3 that's actually the
same structure we would see from the
previous game in this match right they
pretty much the same exact structure but
actually a better version for black so
that's why black plays Bishop to C5
and after B4 Bishop to B6 and this is a
pretty high level uh Battleground let's
say white has it was like Bishop to E3
Bishop D2 this was played by Hikaru with
the white pieces against Wesley so in
the recently played American Cup
um
it was played by pretty much every top
player in the world Magnus Levon Wesley
Hikaru Anish uh you you name him so and
it's considered pretty safe for black
that's why people kind of think if I
want to find ideas in this line I need
to look here and
that's more a matter of fashion rather
than the objective value because both
Bishop to B4 and Bishop to C5 are uh
fully playable moves but you want to
look in the direction more so where it's
fashionable that being said if you're
playing this in a world championship
match you'd probably be should be doing
comprehensive preparation ready for
basically any legal move out of your
opponent's disposal so Bishop C5 coming
as a surprise not a very good sign for
Dane
yeah and then they're having quite a bit
of a tank uh in this position he's been
it's been about 10 minutes
now Queen G3 feels like a very direct
approach here you're immediately
threatening the pawn on G7 but the fact
that he's taking his time of course one
always considers development when you're
faced with a move that you were not
prepared with and what comes to my mind
is a move like Bishop D3 here take out
that Bishop start eyeing that eight
seven Pawn in case of a castle attack
can be built and you just simply want to
get your own King to safety
is that an approach in this kind of a in
this kind of an opening Fabi you can can
ding in fact be just looking at simply
completing his development now that it's
clear that this might not be the exact
position that he's had in his
preparation
yeah I think Bishop D3 is definitely on
his radar
but he needs to have a sense of urgency
in this position because let's say after
Bishop D3 black Castle is short
and avoid simply Castle short
black plays D6
unless you have some tactics involving
the H7 Pawn but I don't see them
immediately you can attack that pawn but
G6 seems to safely defend it for example
Queen E4 G6
and you know black has the idea of
Bishop 5 as well so
white can't just make generic developing
moves it'll be an equal position I mean
certainly white is not you know worse
after D6
but white needs to play concretely
because in this situation in the match
he he can't just afford a short draw in
the opening you know he needs to play
for a win so that's why he played Queen
G3
and you hit the nail on the head that
white needs to be Concrete in this
position no time to slow it down and
indeed ding does go for the most direct
line that we have been discussing Queen
G3 on the board Robert this is going to
be a fire fight starting from move 10.
yeah this is the best version of the
line we were just looking at because if
uh black plays King f8 and we can go
with this bishop D3 and you play D6
guess what your king is still in the
center you haven't castled which means
your king and Rook are kind of in each
other's path and if white just
eventually castles King side you can
launch an attack against this black king
so I think Queen G3 is the good starting
point dangling knew that he knew it
immediately he didn't have to think to
be told that but he's just trying to
figure out his continuation here and I
think that for Yan uh I would probably
lean on King f8 as Fabi said G6 allowing
Bishop G5 or Bishop H6 into these dark
squares that doesn't look very appealing
and castling giving up the exchange I
probably wouldn't want to venture into
those Waters considering the match
situation so king of fate I would play
but I'm curious what Jan has in store
for us considering he's the one to
prepare this he's the one playing
quickly when he gets back to a seat I'm
sure he will tell us what he has in mind
I think the issue is that it's gonna be
very difficult for ding to
outplay on when Giannis you know Guided
by a very powerful computer preparation
so the main hope is that
yawn's preparation is not comprehensive
because it is sort of a sideline I mean
it's it's one of the theoretical uh
directions and chess you know it's it's
a very popular line
but it is possible to let's say he's
prepared the next few moves but he he
hasn't prepared
um and we see him quickly play King of
he hasn't prepared this in absolute
detail where he knows every move for the
next you know
10 15 moves at some point he'll be
surprised and that's where your hope is
to tell play your opponent for example
yesterday ding was very well prepared
but when he was confronted suddenly with
the new position after Bishop A2 he did
quickly uh go slightly Australia and got
in a dubious position we could see
something similar like that today where
they have a position which from a
theoretical objective point of view Jan
knows is kind of balanced but at some
point he will have some slight problems
to face because he won't be in his
preparation for the rest of the game
the direction here after Bishop D3
what direction
so I think logically black should play
D6
F4 looks extremely logical to me and I'm
wondering can black take on E5 I know I
said it's a bad move before but after
Bishop B5 I'm wondering can I play F6
Bishop C7
Queen E7
and it's a little bit uncomfortable and
I'm not saying that this is amazing for
black but maybe it's enough to equalize
the game eventually because let's say
the
let's say King to F1
I'm thinking black can develop Bishop B6
Rook C8 next uh like Black's pieces May
quickly come into the game and the extra
Pawn for white is those doubled C pawns
maybe it's not a big deal maybe black is
more or less
on the verge of equalizing these type of
these types of positions
I think he again for the second time in
a row just goes into a sink in this
position after King f8 it's clear that
Jan is prepared and then is in how
surprising is that when Yan decides to
play the English Pawn opening starts
with one C4 goes into this extremely
concrete variation with Knight E5 with
the default on push but with this one uh
different direction of the bishop
Retreat to C5 we see ding go into a
think tank and on the other hand we've
seen Yan have this approach right even
against ding's French he chose to play A
variation not the most topical one not
the not the one that he usually does but
simply not walking into things
preparation and there as well thing was
indeed taking a lot of time in a world
championship match shabby with your
experience how discomforting is it that
when you're white and you want to be the
one calling the action from the very
start in the opening but then you just
feel that it's your opponent who's
actually backlashed and come back with a
better preparation and you need to now
start thinking early on
well yeah you said it everyone wants to
be calling the shots and that's why it's
very often a battle of who gets the
first surprise in and it's not even so
much of the objective quality of the
move
because Bishop A5 we know is a good move
you know Bishop before earlier on the
game was also a good move but you want
to be able to get
uh your sort of surprising and as long
as it's not very bad as long as it's
decent then the surprise value uh is the
most important factor it's not like I
have all sorts of good moves and I can
play any one of them because you can
play a good move and then you get
surprised later on and you end up
getting under pressure so you want to
make your opponent think as early as
possible and that's what uh that's what
Yan is going for it's just smart
preparation
uh it's it's I think how people
generally should at the top level be
approaching openings and how they
usually do so these days Bobby you're
gonna love this Jana palmchi has had
this position before from the white side
in a title Tuesday back in 2020.
who who played it against him he played
against uh Jose Gabriel cardoso
okay you know here's but the point is he
has experience on the white side which
may have led him to look into this
variation
yeah for sure that
people think that title Tuesday is all
just like fun and games and for the most
part it is but sometimes you get an
opening surprise and then you just like
you're curious curiosity hits you and
you're like okay I got to check this
very often maybe it's you know it's
something random it wasn't even good but
sometimes it turns out being uh valuable
knowledge that you have so
yeah I think I think we've all been
there where you know you get surprised
in the opening and some Blitz game you
check it and it turns out it wasn't that
wasn't that bad
this is what happened sorry Robin I just
want to talk about title Tuesday here
because Bobby said it's all fun and
games I have to say I mean have you
taken a look at the playing field of a
title Tuesday it is insane every time
that I've I've been able to play that it
just feels like it's the strongest Elite
event you've got the best players
playing in the world it's a lot of fun
to watch and it's definitely very
dramatic but that just feels like a
world-class event every single week it's
insane
oh for sure yeah it's it's this pretty
much the strongest weekly event you can
possibly imagine very often it's
stronger than you know like a world
championship in in Blitz and Rapid but
uh still a lot of players a lot of the
top guys are not taking it you know
super seriously we see a lot of guys
streaming sometimes drinking sometimes
playing you know playing with their
friends hanging around and distracting
them and uh so it's not
it's not the same level of concentration
that you would you know expect from from
some other events it's funny Robert you
know we're we're thinking of one guy
weren't we
just wondering when everyone's mind and
Robert you were telling us about this
game which in fact the end up she has
had with the white pieces in a title
Tuesday how did his opponent respond
with black hair
yeah no I was putting the moves on the
board and H5 was an idea that Fabi had
talked about and it was played in that
game so it's very likely that we'll see
that again and just to sort of show some
of the more moves that happened it was a
capture on E5 and in this position black
was able to play the move Bishop G4
trying to go after this King on the
e-file and you can see the evaluation
bar saying black is completely fine here
so Jan maybe inspired by a game he
played from the white side three years
ago in title Tuesday
yeah this is the the whole point behind
the the H5 push it's not to play H4 so
much that is one of the ideas so it's
more so to be able to take Play Bishop
G4 and white is kind of obligated to
capture on G4
and after hd4 to get out of that nasty
pin white should Castle well then black
can you know take on H4 with the queen
Queen takes Rook text reactor and
endgame which is probably very very
close to equality Bishop takes C7
as long as white doesn't get made to
down the H file I guess it will probably
turn into equality so
yeah this is going to be tough because
ding will have to be watching out for
these ideas which are not at all evident
uh immediately maybe this is why Bishop
D3 instead of Bishop to E2
is perhaps a more precise move
okay so it's right here so you're saying
trying to bring the bishop to D3 but you
can't and this well not I'm not here but
immediately
yeah I feel like this is the this is a
super critical move of course white has
a tough choice Bishop E2 or Bishop D3
I think you're right though Bishop D3
does make sense I mean it's also a more
active diagonal not that Black's
castling anymore but it does stare
further into Black's camp and I think D6
we're presuming is automatic in most of
these positions I think black is kind of
yeah black has to because if you don't
free that Bishop up then you're going to
be left with a really lousy position and
you can play B6 but that doesn't
actually free the bishop because it
white always has like Bishop T4 ideas
so
yeah this doesn't look super good for
black
you want and especially you want to get
rid of the E5 pump because that pawn is
creating some sort of like
um it's kind of kind of cutting the
board in half so black needs to be able
to have access to the king side but that
pawn on E5 is is cutting off access so
D6 is pretty much a given and here
Bishop to F4 is the first move which
comes to mind with Bishop G5
doesn't make sense because of Queen E8
so which before really comes to mind
yeah just to put that on the board
fabi's point is that Bishop G5 you
attacked the queen but you invite it to
a better Square where there's a pin
along the e-file and so I mean I just
want to take a step back just a quick
moment here that in the game right if we
just go back to the live board the last
book played was King to f8 so for people
who are watching at home who may be
thinking my coach taught me to always
Castle it's not always it is situation
dependent and oftentimes with these high
level Grand Masters like Fabiano caruana
and the two players in the world
championship match it's do as they say
not necessarily as they do because in
this position king of Fate was kind of
forced if you castled we went over this
a little a bit ago but if you weren't
here Bishop H6 is overwhelming Checkmate
is threatened on the spot you can't take
this bishop it goes against the rules of
Chess I'm sorry to say and in order to
stop checking it you'd have to push your
pawn and then you lose your Rook for a
bishop that is not a good Material
Exchange so hassling not available to
you pushing your Pawn would have
weakened all of these dark squares
around the black king side and we're
showing lines that involve Bishop to G5
the bishop could also go to H6 which
would stop black from castling and white
has a huge initiative so Jan prepared
this line he was willing to say I don't
have to Castle in this game my king will
sit on f8 and that's okay because I
defend my G7 Pawn I don't give away
those Key Dark squares I'm not losing a
rook for a bishop and that's why we have
seen Jan avoid castling and that could
be a problem for him his King will
remain towards the center his Rook may
not get in the game that is one of the
reasons why H5 was played in that Blitz
game and made in fact we played in this
world championship classical game but
it's not going to be easy to coordinate
for black we'll see if Jan has prepared
this very deeply because he's gonna need
that he's gonna need to rely on
Preparation and his skill set to get out
of this position where his King and
Rooker in each other's way Robert not
only has Jan played this he's faced it
right as you were mentioning in a 2020
title Tuesday a game with the white
piece is and that just begs the question
that in today's time in this modern era
where we see so much rapid and Blitz
being played at the highest level where
we see intense preparation such big
tournaments happen how important is it
to actually study the games of your
opponent and to prepare against the
games of your opponent which have been
played in a different format in the
rapid format or the blitz format and the
fact that Ding is thinking right now was
this a little slip by team ding to
actually not be aware that Jan in fact
did have this position and could be
familiar with these setups Bobby what's
your take in it when you're preparing
for these big tournaments for the
Champions chess store would you how
important is it how critical is it to
actually look at the games played online
in these faster time controls
I do feel like it was a slip knot to
analyze Bishop C5 but not because of
that reason and the reason why I say
that is because
these days any player you look at will
have hundreds of games played in you
know Blitz events rapid events online
events and you cannot go through every
single game
it's just too much there's too much
information out there and you'll end up
distracting yourself a lot of people
even just play stuff that they wouldn't
normally play because it ends up being
confusing information and more of a
um more of a distraction than actual uh
you know
constructive information to have so if
you're looking at the your opponent's
tree or their recent games usually
people will throw out all those like
title Tuesday games just because people
tend to play random stuff they tend to
not play their main openings because
there's not as much at stake compared to
you know let's say a world Blitz
Championship or World rapid Championship
where so depending on let's say the the
caliber of the event people will assign
uh more or less importance to the games
I think that a title Tuesday game played
in three years ago
probably not something that you should
be really concentrating on too much but
if you're playing this variation you
should still analyze Bishop C5 just
because it's one of the possible logical
moves that someone could could play I
mean uh I would understand
you're playing some normal event you
know you don't analyze Bishop C5 like
fully understand that
um might even expect it but we're a
world championship it's just a different
level you you need to have all the moves
taken care of so you don't end up in
this sort of situation which ding is it
now where he's playing against the
computer
uh he's playing against the best
possible preparation and he has to try
to outplay that on his own over the
board just not a situation you want to
be in that being said I very often
people who are equipped with very
powerful preparation once they get out
of it they can slip into complacency
this has happened to me many times I'm
sure that it's a common occurrence among
many players so it's not always the case
that just because you're well prepared
that means that you will continue to
play at your very best afterwards you
you might
um lose some concentration because the
feeling of preparation the feeling of I
I already got the first Victory out
preparing my opponent it can relax you
and that's not an ideal uh state for for
playing chess I totally get that in the
grief Bobby and a big question I have is
not so much about the time control of a
gameplay that was a Blitz game but when
you are preparing for an opponent do you
look at a position and look at what they
played from both colors because maybe
that's what was missing here that Ding
Loren didn't check if Jan has played
this not just from the black side but
from the white side as well because I
think oftentimes we narrow our tree
there's so many games out there as you
said that we think all right I'm gonna
play this line what has Jan played as
the black pieces sometimes you don't
think maybe he's faced this from the
white side as well
yeah certainly it is a good strategy if
you're preparing a very specific opening
just to curate all your opponent's games
in that very you know narrow line for
example the E4 line you can expect that
maybe yawn only has you know half a
dozen games throughout his career in the
in the E4 variation of the reverse
Sicilian it's easily possible I like
myself I probably only have I probably
have like five six games there so you
could easily go through that information
and it might be might be helpful to
it certainly would have alerted
their uh their team to the possibility
of Bishop C5 like once you get it on
your radar you're just like oh I I
should I should check this because
suddenly I'm curious about it if if you
don't check it it's just because you
you got distracted by other more
pressing issues like let's say the
bishop A5 variation the bishop B4
variation and so on and and then you
forgot to broaden your search in terms
of what to analyze
yeah
and while very important details there
on opening preparation and a position
that we have once again a fresh position
out of the opening in this world
championship match we haven't seen this
line uh being played and ding makes his
decision to the square for the bishop
and he decides to put it in front of the
king Bishop E2 at least visually it
looks a little less aggressive but the
idea of placing the bishop on the long
diagonal can also happen eventually from
that F3 square and Yan once again
showing that he knows what he's doing
comes back to the board and just in a
couple of seconds makes a direct move
attacks that center with the move D6
also opening up that bishop and see it
and now it's a big question today what
does he want to do with his Central Pawn
the E5 Pawn if you trade it on D6 it
allows black to recapture with a Tempo
that might not be the option that is
most appealing here but if you don't is
it time to Simply shot castle and say if
you take my E5 Pawn I'll be the one
coming in with my look to the temple
hitting that Queen on the open D file I
think there's a critical distinction
between the bishop being on D3 and E2
Fabi had mentioned how Bishop G5 in
another variation we met by a pin of the
e-pawn Let's uh just put this on the
board with Queen E8 but that no longer
pins the pawn so maybe that does give a
white a little bit more flexibility for
example just off the top of mind you can
make this move Rook to D1 uh there's no
issue down the E Line black can
certainly not take on E5 with either
piece because this Rook will slam on the
back rank if you take with the pawn Rook
d8 happens I win your queen and if you
instead of taking with the pawn there to
put the queen just to show this end of
variation that ends in check mate even
worse so Dane quickly decided to defend
the pawn rather than Play Bishop G5 and
maybe it's a part of his overall plan
just to play a little bit more quickly
speed up and while Fabi had mentioned
this a long time ago you're choosing
between two good options the bishop G5
and Bishop F4 he decides to sit on that
four and defend the pawn I'm really
interested in the variation I think that
Jan will play his move quickly so we'll
see what he wants but the move I'm
looking at is Queen seven
and the idea is if you Castle short I
want to take on E5 Bishop takes E5 F6
and then you are forced to sacrifice a
piece I think you can play Bishop C7
Queen E2 and some Rook to E1 but I think
in either case there's Bishop takes F2
like Rook if you want I think it's
actually important
like Ruby one might have other issues
but Bishop takes up two especially like
just equalizes at least on the spot and
especially with Rook FT1 because if if
not for Bishop F2 like if black doesn't
have that resource at all for example
some Queen C4 I think Bishop D6 suddenly
becomes very very potentially dangerous
um at least to the naked eye it might
still be completely fine for black of
course but that safety another Bishop
takes up too it completely solves the
issue for black so Queen E7 is the move
that really comes to mind here I wonder
what
what ding would play Rook D1 looks like
a very critical option I just want to
show everybody what was happening here
in the event of Rook a to E1 because
it's such a beautiful tactical uh eye
that you have that Bishop takes F2 check
the big problem is that if the Rook
takes on F2 that would be good except
your Rook on E1 would then be loose the
queen is not in contact thank you very
much black wins the game after stealing
material and if you have to take with
the queen Bobby's whole point is that in
the event of a queen trade black is just
in time to play them with King F7 Bishop
E6 the Rooks get connected there are no
more issues for black so beautiful
variation Fabi I just want to show
everybody what was going on in that big
brain of yours
and and here black would even be a tiny
bit better although it's it's almost
certainly a draw but because of the
doubled C pawns black can at least uh
pretend that he's playing for a win
which is always a pleasant feeling
so after Queen E7 I don't know Rook D1
is very critical isn't it
okay
I was just thinking like isn't H5 what
we were kind of H5 H4 is what we were
looking at right after H5 white of
course can take on D6 but H5 was the
game that actually was the exact game
where Beyond was white against uh
cardoso right this is what we were
looking at
but now white can take on D6 right or
maybe the pawn stock is okay for black
H5 ed6 CD
Bishop takes D6
otherwise H yeah Queen D6 looks like the
best move
I guess take take followed by Bishop to
E6 I I'm thinking black is more or less
um
I don't know King E7 first or Bishop B6
first but more black is probably more or
less within Equalization here
despite the upon deficit would you like
to have this position as black would you
feel comfortable in your uh drawing
chances
I would feel
pretty confident that I'm not going to
lose this
because I'm quickly playing King E7 Rook
C8 B6 Rook C5
uh
yeah it's it's hard to imagine
like if the better question is if you're
white do you think that you can win this
against yeah
while he's prepared and the answer does
probably uh not on a not on a normal day
wow big decisions here Robin
Robert that Yan needs to take currently
well he is in his resting area he is
thinking about what to respond after
ding Lawrence Bishop F4 the lines that
we were seeing Jan might end up in an
end game down a pond but enough
compensation given things upon structure
and we see that Yan lost in thought
clearly thinking he has kept up the
momentum so it wasn't a big surprise for
him being C4 but the position could go
either ways right now it is a position
that is full of action and we will be
back with Yan's decision on the other
side of this break
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
World Quant is an official partner of
the chesscom broadcast of the fide World
Championship they are a global firm that
builds complex mathematical models to
identify market inefficiencies now World
Quant brain is bringing together its
International Quan championship and the
chess Community to hunt down the next
generation of Quant Finance Specialists
because let's admit it nobody knows how
to analyze a position better than a
chess player if you think you have what
it takes register for the International
Championship you've got to head over to
go.chess.com iqc or use the command iqc
in chat for more details as we Deep dive
into the details of this fantastic
opening that we've had in a game 10 of
the match we see Jana palmnessi has
returned to the board and he is thinking
how to take care of the current threat
that is the pressure on the D6 Pawn
right now yandere having a thing
singling was the one who decided to go
for the English but he's the one who
slowed down in the opening phase
currently about 15 minutes behind on the
clock Bishop F4 was things last move the
idea is clear he wants to put pressure
on the D6 Pawn slide over that Queen
side rip from A1 all the way to D1 start
attacking and we have been looking at a
potential end game that could occur
where in fact nepo will be down upon
that his compensation will lie in the
double Pawns of the sea lion and Fabi
Robert I want to just Deep dive into
that because there is a big chance of
that actually happening so just to
evaluate that end game that if you're
the line that you were looking at with
Queen to E7 with the Rook sliding on to
D1 if we can uh just have that on the
board and after H5 everything
potentially gets traded on by the way
Jan has made the move Queen E7 and now
it's up to ding whether he decides to go
for it or not but it's a big possibility
trades on D6 Queen D6 eventually the
Queens will also be trade it off and
this end game that we have been
discussing and if Yan was to develop his
Bishop with the idea of The Rook coming
on attacking the C4 Pawn how much poison
is there really in the position now
looking at it it looks like it should be
fine for black but white also has his
trunks you're up upon the Rook will
slide back to the D4 Square you're not
going to win the C4 Pawn very soon the
King which is still in the center can
step up to D2 the other Rook can join
the activity by sliding down to the B
file Bobby what's the chances of this
end game posing actual questions to Yan
well yeah let's see concretely what I
would do here a move that comes to mind
as you said is King to D2
King to E7 let's say Rook to D4
Rook a to C8
Rook to B1 these moves kind of all come
very naturally B6
and maybe white can fix the H5 with H4
you can see at least that part is fixed
on a light Square
but okay black and play Work C5 black
and play G6 the position is so so super
solid for black
I don't really see this being a serious
Advantage at all or or even a tiny one I
just don't see like even if you play
Rook to B5 here
and I play Rook to C5 let's say I'm
ready to trade on that square
and what if you take take
even in a bishop end game it would just
be a complete draw
so
but specifically here The Rook is
actually
rather awkwardly placed it can't I mean
work out four Rook B8 you know black is
actually the one getting some activity
first
and I don't think we'll have any
problems so yeah I'm not seeing the the
huge danger in this end game
I if I were doing I would be looking for
other avenues
and I briefly considered Queen E7 long
Castle
but I feel like it just loses for white
so I stopped considering it
um
D takes E5 Bishop B5 F6 is certainly
coming to mind
Bishop's seven Queen E2 probably when
you mentioned long Castle even the eval
bar lost the plot it went up it went
down it didn't know what to make of it
definitely an interesting option go on
well it would be like it would be great
for white in this position if your word
for the fact that white was getting
mated
which is sometimes the case in chess but
your only issue is that you're in
checkmate
but here here's our other serious one
for example Rook to d8 King to F7 Rook 8
shaped Bishop to A3 followed by
Checkmate on B2
um
I don't think this is gonna happen
but yeah I was just looking for some
kind of creative options for white to
uh to mix it up but long Castle is too
much
so Rook D1 or short Castle but short
Castle I just think like concretely just
doesn't work out for like taking F6
doesn't seem like there's much there for
what to hope for
so Rook D1 is the only move that's like
very obvious to Me Maybe H4 comes to
mind but also rather artificial moves I
wouldn't consider it too much
and H4 I guess is a what's the point of
H4 because we were looking at some lines
where after Rook D1 black played H5 and
then white played H4 to stop black from
making progress over there what would be
your main thought about starting with H4
well I guess I'm just worried about this
Rook D1 H5 idea and I don't see other
like very obvious moves for black
besides HIV ideas so I'm just trying to
get ahead of my opponent the thing is
after h4a5 I don't really see what what
I have besides Rook D1 which is better
than
Rook D1 so it kind of seems to lead to a
very similar position Rook D1 as we
mentioned is now met by Bishop to G4 or
uh first take 25 and then Bishop G4
although they're both they're both
playable so I don't know which is better
but this this is very decent for black
like here
I don't think white has any serious
chances for an advantage
um
like white can try F3 here but it's more
likely just to lead to a bad position F3
Rook to E8 I guess
uh fg4 Queen E5 actually it's probably
just leading to an equal position not a
bad position take take rookie d8 black
is lucky to have Rook to E8
take take actually white wins upon again
G takes H5 but with the Obstacle of
Bishops along with the rather damaged
structure on the king side I think that
a draw is like let's say root H6 here
for example
draw is a very likely result
because black has his own counter player
Rook A6 and so on you know white has
maybe some G4 G5 someday but the
position is going to be very balanced
so Rook D1 yeah and we're all right is
this direct transposition to the to the
young game against cardoso
yeah you know it was in that game
just to make sure I have my mind on my
brain working correctly it's still only
5 48 in the morning uh it was
actually yeah H5 H4 okay I see an idea I
see one
go for H1 Bishop G5 let's do this you
can't take on E5 you mentioned similar
stuff in a
slightly different position and if the
queen goes back to E8 I Castle short now
you don't have H4 and you don't have
Queen E5 you don't have de5 I'm happy
about this
development
I think that this is a minor success for
white
starting to look like a bit of pressure
for white so maybe after Bishop 25 F6 is
a critical move
is that possible
that is a brave decision I mean it looks
really ugly but your point I guess is
after Pawn takes Pawn takes first of all
there's no Bishop H6 check that's why
the pawn is no longer on H7 it's on H5
The Rook covers the square this bishop
can come out to G4
it's it's a very positionally unclear
uh situation because you take only three
I don't take what the queen of course
with white I take it with the palm
try to trade those Queens I don't want
to trade Queens
can I play
into H4
so you're gonna give up pawns with check
because you are still a brave man uh
computer is not approving the queen C3 I
thought King F2 and then if I can get
Rook F1 King G1 castle by hand
uh at least my king is going to safety
your king is long term a little bit on
the weaker side
I don't see this as I mean obviously bad
for what it might be bad for white but
not
immediately evident why
I agree but that's when these positions
get very tempting but unfortunately Jan
has likely studied these types of
positions whereas ding is clearly on his
own so you're you're kind of lured into
it and black isn't much better we see
the evaluation bar it's only one extra
Pawn but black has the worst King but I
think Jan you know he has to have looked
deeply into these positions otherwise
it's so risky
yeah I mean unless you have looked
deeply in this position the chances of
making a move like F6 after Bishop G5
it's just so difficult but the good news
is that even if you haven't looked at it
so deeply is there another move for
black here you pointed out that E5
cannot be taken after Queen E7 the last
thing you want to do is yes let's just
point that line out one more time Robert
Queen E5 you trade and Rook d8 would be
game over that's a Checkmate that is not
gonna happen so even if you don't like
the move F6 after Bishop comes on G5 and
hits that Queen on E7 it's hard to come
up with an alternative you don't want to
fall back to E8 because that's just a
waste of time but I have to say that F6
I would love to see that happen on the
board simply because that Bond structure
it just looks like long term that is
where both sides can create chances and
if it's an objectively equal position
that's exactly what ding wants out of
this game right just some practical
chances if he's going to evaluate the
answering end game of the trades in the
current live board as we see on D6 as
one that Jan will have no trouble out of
as an endgame where yes he's up upon
riyan has enough chances and enough
counter play on the C file to hold his
own that is not what ding wants and
wants to aim for with the white pieces
in this game 10 which is just makes me
feel that Bishop G5 is the option that
Ding might be tempted to play especially
if he feels that F6 is the only move
Robert
yeah no I think the lines that we were
just looking at where even though the
computer says black is slightly better
it's very enterprising stuff and it's
very unclear I think that's the good
thing when you're visualizing this
position from dingley Run's perspective
but the bad news is he probably feels
like he's within Beyond apologies
preparation and that's where it starts
to feel uncomfortable because in a Blitz
game he played Bishop G5 allow F6 he'd
probably win the game most of the time
just because to show this position once
more how just disastrous it looks in
front of this black king that king is
not going anywhere it's wide open and
we've been looking at Bishop to E3 as
the way to stop any pressure down the
e-file and in the event of these trades
Queen E5 is a Saving Grace it's also a
pretty natural move to consider once
you've gotten to this point because
you're offering Queen trade threatening
this Pawn over here still putting
pressure on the E3 Pawn but as Fabiano
said I mean if the Queens can stay on
then the black king will look worse off
than the white king and even in the
event of a queen trade also I mean this
is one of the ugliest Pawn structures I
think we'll ever see so I just want to I
don't know where do I move my Rook okay
go to D5 I'll lose C3 with check so
let's go here and just get to this
position like H5 is loose and actually
the engine says white is slightly better
so it's the worst pause structure I
think we could ever possibly imagine uh
but I was going to point out that black
spawn structure isn't exactly healthy
either
yeah and also
ugly pawns which can't be attacked are
not that bad
and The Rook on D4 is really like the
nice thing about this Pawn structure is
that it creates a lot of open lines it's
like I want to you know find the beauty
in in everything so it's finding the
beauty in this Pawn structure it's
creating a lot of open lines for the h
file the defiled file and work on D4 has
a lot of potential little outposts to
move to F4 potentially D4 it's a very
nice Rook
but still I feel like let's say Bishop
to E6 here
and
okay you can take that pawn but still
black is super solid and white can't
create a past Pawn
and king T can I go to E7 or is that
allowing Rook T probably not rookie four
well not a big deal so
yeah white you'd prefer white a little
bit for sure but you can't create a pass
Pawn so you would still assume that
objectively it's rather close to to
equality
maybe black had something better after
Rook to D4 besides giving up
the pawn with uh with Queen takes G3
like I can start with
Bishop to E6 here and if you Castle then
I'll take on G3 right I was hoping on
the board somehow and go for an attack
yeah but Rook F4 is dropping the pawn
potentially I don't know if you are
super happy to take that pawn on C3 but
it's definitely a consideration
of course the engine says ever so
slightly better for black
but it's it's a complex position because
white is going to play Rook to F1
followed by King's G1 and it just attack
that F6 pawn and yeah black has to deal
with some King safety issues and I saw
the chat didn't uh someone on the
featured chat
took exception to my castling by hand
uh mentioned because how else do you
Castle I guess that's that's true
[Laughter]
but uh but I guess that's sort of a
saying when you've lost your casting
rights and you try to you know fix it by
playing uh rooked F1 followed by King to
G1
so what should we call it besides
castling by hand
I like gasoline by hand I think the
normal one would be castling with pieces
and this one because you're sort of not
doing it automatically Abby I think it
makes a lot of sense I'm with Team
castling by hand okay but what how do
you castle if not with pieces
delayed Castle
that's that makes sense how about the
step by step
by step sounds like a sounds like a
dance as well
well manual castings that's what it's
called
man it looks hustling I love it
isn't manual casting the same as casting
by hand like isn't that
what it is yeah that's what I would
think oh
great question
look at this username is that say Fabi
fabiable
is that like if I
start my own accessible adjacent company
that one's a winner it is the bong cloud
castle because you place the King on F2
and then you bring it back I like that
one I like the sound of a bombing cloud
castle
yeah but it's not the bunk clock it's a
bunk car is bringing the king up to E2
so I feel like that's uh
not to hate on chat sorry I'm sorry well
I'm not really sorry but I'm fake sorry
uh but yeah we'll we'll come up with a
good term somebody I'm sure will be
creative there
wow oh I like that one
what is it is it casting the scenic
route
well whatever you want to call it ding's
taking a decision he goes by well the
automatic gasoline or castle by pieces
or the quick Castle however you want to
call it it is on the board he decides to
not play the options that we were
discussing and it is a critical moment
in this position and ding finally makes
his decision he has taken a lot of time
he's down by almost 25 minutes on the
clock at 23 minutes on the clock is it
something that he needs to start
thinking about and start taking the
preceding decisions faster now Robert
why did we consider this move that's
what I'm trying to figure out right now
like we were talking about castling in a
different position then after H5 we kind
of lost the thread a little bit here but
Cass Lake makes perfect sense because
Fabi talked us through variations before
where black tries to take on E5 and play
F6 these no longer work with the Rook
already stationed on D1 when it worked
is when The Rook was back over here so I
feel like casting is just a very natural
and good move and Jan still has a lot to
prove here because white will maintain
the pressure in the center of the board
I love ding's move I think that this
won't be that easy for Yan to get out of
and his preparation will have to keep on
going I'll have to show it to us because
King's on f8 all of White's pieces on
very natural squares thus far there's
pressure on D6 that can be captured at
some moment I don't know about this I
mean what is Yan gonna play is it really
H4 because the queen can slide over to
D3 and once again the E5 Pawn cannot be
captured because of background problems
yeah I think we only didn't consider the
move because it just allows H4 and it
feels like you want to cut into Black's
plans but once you see the move then you
see H4 Queen to D3 and you don't want to
take only five H3 is of course always an
option but uh you know I don't see why
white can't simply responded with G3
and then the bishop goes to F3
it covers that diagonal and the root
comes to you one like in an ideal world
you can see how uh black is certainly
under
a lot of pressure here black has to come
up with something rather quickly but I
think H4 must be the move and the
question is after Queen D3 what uh what
is the follow-up
I hope that was rhetorical because I
don't have the answer
well I'm I'm not a 100 sure myself if
you've gone H5 you've gone H4 you got to
get that H3 in and then play first think
later strategy
is that is that how we play World
Championships play first thing later
that's how we do the analysis in these
positions and also H3 just looks like
such a direct option here and I think we
just have to Deep dive a little bit into
it what happens after H3 and how is
white responding to that uh Abby
yeah so it is possible of course to play
G3 but I'm wondering what if we ignore
that threat what if I play Bishop to F3
here
H22 Rook FT1 I don't care about your
king size stuff
because with the bishop on G3 for
example Queen H4 is met by Bishop to G3
I think I cover all of the possible
threats on the king side and the more
relevant
uh detail in the position is that D6 is
following and Black's King is still in
the center as you've highlighted and
blackism's
serious trouble here you know he's he's
probably on the verge of losing so
that's why I don't know if H3 is a good
idea because
maybe it's not really creating a uh very
Salient threat
maybe we need to develop Bishop to E6
and again we're kind of
tempting white into end game which we're
happy to go for because
the end game is our refuge the King on
f8 is no longer a weakness it becomes a
strength on the E7 Square
so again I would be thinking Bishop to
F3 here for example is is a crucial move
to consider
and yeah it's still it's pressure it's
not uh
it's it's not like black has equalized
just yet he may equalize but not he
still has to prove it in this position
Bob we have a question for you because
if black doesn't act quickly and just
leaves the king in the center with the
Queens in the board this looks quite
tough for black to defend so that led me
to think that in this position if
they're H4 Queen D3 can black sort of I
I know it's risky but do you have to
take on D6 here or do you can you just
slide the bishop back and go for the
long term against this King
you don't have to take on D6 I I was a
bit concerned that this might be a much
worse version of the end game just
because G5 is such a weakness and it
allows white ideas like F4 potentially
after you take everything for example
Bishop T6 maybe F4 suddenlade option and
black is not only down a pawn
but has some weaknesses to worry about
on the king side so it's not it's not
just about the queen side weaknesses
anymore
and
that's why I don't feel like G5 like it
definitely comes to mind
it's it's playable move for sure but the
other question is maybe white could take
on D6 and then not capture the second
time maybe drop the bishop back after
that like I'm wondering even Bishop to
E3 comes to mind here
Bishop takes E3 F takes E3 I really want
to open that up file I don't care about
the structure I want to play Bishop F3 I
want to play Bishop D5
uh I see the eval is not saying black
isn't like trouble here or anything but
I'm so tempted by this with life even
looking at it still it looks very
tempting yeah because the black king
remains In Harm's Way the white king
safely tucked away and castled so for
all of you watching and trying to think
how do I play this type of position I
was trying to lash out and force the end
game thinking that okay if we got there
that would give black the best chances I
do not like the look of the uncastled
king and that's why fabi's taking
advantage of it saying I actually also
don't like the look of the uncastle king
so to your point Bobby just to show that
one more time that trading Queen still
looks Pleasant for white because of the
inclusion of this Pawn on G5 you would
like your best move would be to push
this Pawn back and play Bishop to E6 but
with the pawn sticking out like a sword
thumb F4 is played you're breaking open
lines and just to further the point that
now H4 is a Target and you'd like to
start pushing your pawns backwards you
can't do that in chess and that means
that they are going to fall under attack
yeah and black can play H3 well first
he'll have to deal with the third Rook
takes E6 so King E7 Rook D4 H3 but white
can play G3 and the thing about this the
structure and the Bishops that we have
on the board the lights for Bishops is
H3 is a long-term weakness if all the
Rooks were swept from the board that
pawn would be unlikely to survive in the
long run
yeah we can imagine
well especially yeah black play some B6
here type taking F2 I think white just
wins this position King code is a D4 uh
eventually
it might actually it might just come to
F4 maybe and or or G4 King G3
immediately might be the the fastest way
and yeah it's not about the queen side
extra Pawn it's about the weak H3 Pawn
so
so G5 would be
a rather risky choice for Yan he's
thinking I don't feel like he's in prep
anymore otherwise he would be
moving moving more quickly than he is
I think he should decide to push that H
Pawn to H4 hitting the queen which seems
a lot natural and whether it's H3 or G5
or another move one thing's for sure
this is already a very exciting middle
game more than what we could have asked
for right out of the opening uh in game
10 right now shot Castle I like that
approach by ding simply because it
doesn't go into an end game immediately
we might still see trades on D6 but ding
here trying to create as many
possibilities as possible to get a full
game in hand and that's exactly what the
math situation requires from him yeah
comes back from the restroom and doesn't
make a move instantly uh but yeah still
expecting H4 I'm still struggling to see
why you didn't like H3 as much as uh as
you as you mentioned that it's not a
move that you're expecting Jan to make
it just feels like it could potentially
be his idea and uh if not H4 H3 if not
the G5 move that we're looking at is
there a way for black to find Harmony
Bishop E6 try and just develop as
quickly is that slower approach more
what you're expecting from Yan right now
in this position after H4 hitting that
Queen just simply developing with the
bishop well this is just a pure
calculation position so I think that he
will if he's not in his preparation
he'll have to sit down and just
calculate his way to equality and the
reason I don't think this h4h3 is so
tempting is because after Bishop F3 it
felt like it wasn't such an easy
position for black although there may be
resources for him there
uh I was briefly thinking about Bishop
G4 here similar to ideas we saw but I
don't think it works out very well
because I think white can take followed
by Rook to E1 or something and it looks
like a very dangerous position for black
so
H4 is definitely coming to mind I mean
you can start with like Bishop to F5 to
stop Queen D3 ideas but
uh
actually Bishop is is an option but then
the question is that after
black plays H4 next move then Queen to
F3 will attack the B7 Pawn
so for example Bishop I thought I'm
thinking Rook FT1 is an option
and and then if H4 Queen to F3
yeah that's very good
and yeah B7 becomes a tender point for
example take only five I think probably
white can
take on B7
and
Rook to E8 it's still it's still complex
but you know maybe white moves a bishop
somewhere I don't know exactly where
maybe to F1
and yeah complex position because if
black keeps this E5 stronghold like
let's say F6 then uh you know there's no
clear way for white to make inroads into
the structure so
rather actually maybe Bishop's F1 was
the wrong way maybe there was something
super Sharp
like
I'm not quite seeing it
I was trying some kind of Bishop G4
stuff but I don't think it works
uh Bishop before rookie five Bishop B6
unfortunately
so obviously these tactics are
definitely
some sometimes available but not not
specifically here
could it just be Bishop F3 just being a
more active Square
and then if E4 then you can take on C7
is that is it that simple or is there
even
Rook D5 is also coming to mind but it's
very complicated position clearly
yeah Rook D5 Bishop to E6 and
what's and then vertex E4 that was my
idea Bishop default Queen D5 and it all
falls apart for black
yeah this
this seems to work out I have the whole
variation so yeah that's why Bishop F5
immediately is not
looking super good
okay let's try this H4 I feel like it's
you know sometimes the natural move is
just the best one right H4 Queen D3 in
here
I think a further examination of Bishop
E6 is is necessary because that feels
like a very natural root looking move to
me
but can we just do what you've been kind
of advocating for like Bishop F3 rookie
one just play calm moves where the black
king stays in the center
yeah Bishop to F3 for sure looks like a
good move and the question is is black
ready to take on E5 now because there's
no Queen d8 check anymore so white
will just take back there's no uh
oh because Rook be at Bishop takes E5
and I can't take back and the reasons
Queen d8 apparently I blunder it
terribly but the whole point because
there's F6 F6 here oh but I'll just show
that after Rook takes B7 I was trying to
get tricky with a back rank check you
have to take and at the end of it when
your king moves up to E7 you lose the
Rook but Fabi saw one move deeper than I
did and said F6 well I think it's two
moves F6 Bishop before G5 right
oh and the king gets the G the G7
I think so
and it says it went from great for black
to somehow back to equal which means the
black king is so exposed that it gives
white chances white is going to
sacrifice a piece somehow I don't know
exactly how but
some move to stack a piece in this
position yeah I just want to show
everybody why this suddenly you know is
back to good for black is that in this
check thankfully the pawn is on G5 so
the king gets the G7 I mean Whirlwind
tactics but the king gets to protect
this Rook when that pawn was in G7 you
win The Rook in the corner with it up on
G5 it came there with the tempo the King
goes to G7 to defend the rook and black
would be up a piece in winning this game
this is crazy stuff maybe bishop to D5
after G5 is saving the day for white
um he's saying it's back here okay
right here GI Bishop D5
because if you take take on F4 The Rook
after E1
and
Queen D6 and then there's Queen F5 and
yikes
yeah and then Queen B6 rookie six it's a
very long line but it eventually works
out for white
black king Always In Harm's Way because
it did not Castle
this is scary I mean we keep looking at
these variations and black may have a
couple of only moves just to stay in the
game because the black king is on f8 so
in this position this is why Yan is
thinking so much he knew the plan with
H5 but I guess my big question is is
this where his preparation kind of
stopped he knew the framework but now
that we're in the position he's like
this doesn't actually look so good for
black
yeah I think that this before by the way
it's on the board
yeah H4 played
and I think that this is um the
difficulty because you you can only
prepare so much and then it leads you
know it's objectively equal but it's
still very often his chest is so complex
difficult to find a way even if you know
the evaluation very often it's a
struggle to find the correct path
so Queen CD3 what we expect here Queen
to F3 is playable
because D takes E5 is read by Bishop
takes E5 but it makes less sense than
Queen to D3
to my eye although Queen F3 definitely
deserves some consideration
ending is behind 10 minutes on the clock
and we've often seen this to be a sort
of an internal battle for thing right
how much time to spend especially with
the kind of games that he's had in this
particular World Championship in game
seven he played the most accurate chess
played took care of the most difficult
situation but did not have enough time
and eventually had a collapse with just
seconds left on the clock that backfired
in game eight we saw him try to recover
from that play just a little too quickly
missed a very opportune moment where he
had to calculate through to take his
time wrap the game up at that spot but
he played that move super fast and that
backfired so it's always this very thin
line that how long is too long he does
currently he's behind on the clock by
about 11 minutes and he has to decide
between two squares on the board how
much time would be too much time at this
moment for dang Robert that's a good
question I think part of it is
psychological more than it is specific
to this game where he was worried in
game eight about getting into too much
time trouble and that's why he rushed
some decisions not that the variation
was easy that has been discussed a lot
he did just make the move Queen D3 so he
is playing confident chess right now uh
but back in game eight when he did have
a winning position if he picked up the
Rook that was well within his sights I
mean he is such a strong player an
amazing calculator but he played his
move in just about three four minutes
and he didn't take the time that it
would require it to go all the way to
the end of the line which he fully was
capable of but here in this position
right now loving his chances with the
white pieces we have a very safe King
tucked away on G1 you have a king on f8
that is not happy to be there it was
forced to that square based on Jan's
opening but he may be regretting it to
some extent and he's chilling in the
rest area you know he's going to be
staring at the board from over there but
I I just don't think he's very happy
like chill is not what he is internally
yep absolutely and in fact thing is uh
fighting the Demons of the past games
his situation with the clock as well as
of course uh the position on the board
and his opponent we did run a poll uh
with asking whose dings our position in
this match and our chat had to say 60 of
it felt that it is the clock that has
been determining these decisions and
these critical moments and of course
he's the opponent that he's playing an
absolute Beast as well but doing equally
fighting the clock his own psychological
demons as well as the position on the
board it's a really nice insight there
and we see once again the players are in
the rest area you got the anti-chairs in
front of us and there is always this big
conversation about whether we should
have live boards in the rest area or not
because very often as fans as
commentators as Spectators as lovers of
the game we're just sort of left with
this highly sort of dense environment
but nothing's happening because you've
got the chairs and the players are
thinking about the position but they're
back in their resting area what's your
take on this Robert tabi either if you
could take this that should that be the
live board where the players have the
opportunity to actually think over
calculate go through the variation in
their rest area
well I think there's an easy solution to
this if you if you give them only one
shared rest area and make it very small
you're not going to want to hang out
there anymore
and they'll probably be at the board
more so but yeah if you give them this
nice comfy you know sofa like who
wouldn't want to be there
well I guess it begs the question when
you're playing such an intense game
Fabiano you played the World Chess
Championship back in 2018 and when
you're playing in that intense
environment is it good for you as a
player to go towards the rest area I
know you've said in the past that
sometimes you get a little bit too
relaxed you get complacent if you're not
at the physical board but do enjoy
stepping away from the board after
you've made your move
I do usually spend a lot of time away
from my board in most tournaments but
that's because I like to look at the
other games that are going on
and in this sort of event there is
really nothing else to look at so I I
think I spend most of my time at the
board and I think it's usually the best
thing
just to you know you have to have your
con uh concentration at its fullest you
you don't want to be away from the war
too much but every player has their own
preferences like at the candidates I
remember Young
quite often in the rest area and he
would have that lounged back relaxed uh
posture and you know he would be he
would be looking at the screens there so
he would still be looking at the
position but in a rather relaxed way
maybe it works for some players maybe it
doesn't work for others
I I think this is this is a very
individual thing so I can't really speak
to it on a general level
that seems very fair fobby and well
speaking of things that you can't
generalize is very individualistic Yan
is a very quick player and he's been
playing very Speedy chess throughout the
match right now he is really slowed down
I mean it was clear that the opening was
within his wheelhouse he just pushed his
Pawn to H4 ding immediately play Queen
D3 is this at all reminiscent of game
eight when it felt like Yan he knew the
opening stage he was able to stabilize
but then ding started putting pressure
on him Beyond slowed down and made an
error I feel like this is a position
where black could go wrong at any moment
now
yeah I absolutely agree and the nice
thing about this one compared to some
other games and during the match which
were very double-edged the nice thing
for me ding's point of view that is is
that this is absolutely risk-free for
white why can at any moment take on D6
and just simplify to an end game so
that's that's a nice safety net to have
in your mind for example uh the game
eight was very double-edged both sides
were playing on nice Edge you know uh
taking very serious risks obviously from
an objective point of view it was only
Jan who ever had a bad position
but from a practical point of view it
was a very double-edged opening for Y2
because you know you're you're left with
this very damaged spawn structure and uh
uh you can easily it can easily go out
of control and you can get a worse
position here white can never really get
worse at least for the moment maybe
later on in the game but with the option
to take on D6 any moment
and we see ding is at the board as well
both players fully concentrated at this
point
I actually wanted to show a funny line
after Queen F3 instead of Queen D3
because we saw dink hesitate for a
moment there
and it's no longer relevant towards the
game but it's still
I'm curious if it's the correct
variation
okay we'll bring up an analysis report
to look at that movie so you're saying
instead of a turn to goes after H4
Queen's under attack only two realistic
squares if Queen F3 which you had been
calling for before what did you think
black was responsible I think okay I was
just looking at the most concrete take
on E5
Bishop E5 Queen E5 looks like you're
losing material but after Rook d8 King
E7 Rook h8 I have this move Bishop's G4
and I think probably Queen G4
is I don't think the two Rooks are as
strong as the queen so I think white
should and the K97 seems safe to me I
don't see how it's getting attacked on
black Neo solely played G6 King F6 maybe
if you're feeling uh frisky and then put
the King on G7
and I don't think black is any works so
I just wanted to show this funny line
because Bishop G4 is is a typical sort
of tactic or sometimes how to regain a
rook which is lost very often in the end
game it's played with the check against
the king in the middle game with the
attack against the queen and so on I'm
doing an instant replay that was six
stuff there giving up in exchange right
now black has a bishop for a rook but
Bishop G4 spied by Fabi and undoubtedly
seen by dingley run because Queen F3 was
a tempting option and as you were
pointing out if you take this rook in
the corner Bishop F3 Bishop after you
see the evaluation going in Black's
favor the reason why is Black's King is
actually quite safe in the center and
there's going to be some Bishop D6 stuff
the C3 Pawn is under attack White's pawn
shops are much worse it's a queen and
one Pawn for two Rooks it's probably
gonna become a queen and two pawns for
the couple Rooks and Black's King is in
no danger whatsoever so really
instructive variation there by Fabi
giving away one Rook just to win it back
and then with the opposite color Bishops
black would really not be in danger at
all so we did see Queen D3 and Jan in
that Think Tank he really wants to
figure this out as you said there's that
bailout option at any moment for white
to take on D6 that's the good news for
dingly Wren but his moves also are quite
simple Bishop F3 rookie one blacks moves
on the other hand very hard to make and
the more that Jan starts to think the
more that I like dingley wren's chances
Fabi I would not envy the task of
playing with the black pieces here
me neither I I don't think that it's
easy for black I'm thinking about the
move G6 at this point
G6
I just want to get my king into some
sort of safety
okay
and yeah Bishop 5 also becomes an option
but now I feel like I have the
possibility
of detect C5 and I have queen d8 king G7
this is what I'm mainly going for he
plays G5 instead okay the most forcing
option as you mentioned before
so now the question is you scared me out
of it Fabi but what's the big question
uh
does white take on D6 does white go for
the end game or does white try to play
with the Queen's on in a middle game
all sorts of options I mean I think
he'll take on D6 here because
even if you want to retreat your Bishop
you might as well take on D6 first
I think cd6 is kind of pretty much
forced
and now the question is do I play Bishop
D6 does white Play Bishop C1 does y Play
Bishop P3 all sorts of moves come to
mind I think you mentioned Bishop C1 as
an option which is is definitely very
logical
yeah I mentioned well G5 I was playing
just to force you to exchange on D6
right because we kept talking the end
game but now that we've looked at it
that still looks very promising for
white but if we play our Bishop back to
C1 how exactly is black going to respond
here this King still is weak on a fade
yeah let's let's try King to G7
definitely coming to mind as a logical
move you know what my move is going to
be I can't do it I was trying to play F4
and then I just remembered that my Pawn
spinned
so if if your opponent plays F4 in a
world championship do you just take
their king or do you say it's a legal
move or do you just take the king and
then leave the plane while you're like
okay I I won I have your king I think
that's how it should be if someone
blunders their King you should be able
to take it uh but now do I push my king
to the corner I don't really like that
with H3 on tap but how does white
actually play this position
it's not a very obvious one it's
Bishop to F3 is very logical for sure
and rubbish one D5 that that can't be a
bad piece can only be a good piece but
black is not under attack immediately
and that Bishop on C5 is a really
beautiful like Queen F6 here really
beautiful both Defender and aggressive
attacker of the dark squares right
you're stopping Rook E1 in many
positions because as you're saying the
bishop is threatening F2 G4 would happen
and that's a big problem for white so G5
hits the First bishop it can't hit the
second one I think ding was correct to
take on D6 and Fabi a really big choice
between Bishop E3 keeping the Queens on
the board or Bishop takes D6 getting
into a queen trade where white is the
only side with winning chances so while
dingley Ren Ponders this all-important
decision we are going to take a quick
break but when we return it's dingley
wren's choice will we see a queenless
position or will we see the attack rage
on that's the big question we'll find
out in just a few minutes
[Music]
thank you
introducing World quad the partner of
the Champions chess tour and chess.com
[Music]
World Quant is a global firm in the
field of quantitative Asset Management
if you don't know what that is it's the
job of building complex mathematical
models that seek to identify Market
inefficiency
for 2023 World Quant brain is bringing
together its International Quant
championship and the award-winning
Champions chess tour to hunt down the
next generation of Quant Finance
Specialists it sounds very exciting you
put your skills in practice in a case
competition where you get a real
Challenge and I signed up
worldquant is seeking new talent and new
energy and it's looking at the world of
Chess to help because nobody knows how
to analyze a position better than a
chess player right no Quan experience no
problem
so do you think you have what it takes
to compete in the international Quant
championship
sign up and be the next Quant champion
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
what is a chess Dynasty
unceasing dominance move after move
again and again and again we have a
resignation we have history he is the
five-time fide World chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time oh my
god did he just blocked yeah he did I'm
Blown Away the game is over
as the Chess World Turns to Kazakhstan
the Magnus Carlson Dynasty is set to
close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs
for two chess Superstars lying in wait
until next time is now
Jan napam Nashi has methodically done
what he needed to do to get another shot
at the title the pressure to seize the
moment this time rests heavily upon him
it's a draw the big missed opportunity
he feels it and wow I haven't seen Yan
like that after a game Robert I don't
know if that's a good signup
dingley Ren knows firsthand what the end
of this dynasty means an unexpected
chance to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Fame dingly Wren held his
ground he has managed to strike back
twice he needs to do it one more time to
level the score
the legacy of this Championship spans
across centuries it reads from the names
of Chess Giants
for the first time in a decade a new
name will raise the trophy and be etched
into chess history
it's the 2023 VA World Championship
whose name will next be called champion
[Music]
it is anything but clear in terms of who
will be the next World Champion but the
man you see on your screen Jana Pomchi
has the inside track a one-point lead
heading into game 10 but he is under
pressure several moves have been played
since the break we do see the Queens
leave the board and while Tanya suchev
she's experiencing technical
difficulties Bobby in the words of the
illustrious Bill Withers it's just the
two of us you and I
we can make it if we try Robert
should we build castles in the sky I
mean Jan didn't build the castle in this
game his King stayed in the center and
here it Still Remains
yeah he didn't manage to castle that's
true but he dinged it and he's actually
probably in a rather Pleasant end game
so I was thinking about this
a little bit
black logically should play Bishop to E6
I think
I can also start with King D7 but anyway
white will
we do indeed see him play Bishop T6
first and now F4 is the critical move I
I think we can expect to see that move
rather quickly played by Dave
and Bobby you said rather quickly so I
just you know while we will dive into
the chest I'm just wondering if he plays
these next couple moves quickly do you
how would you think he rates his winning
chances in this game
I still think it's one of those
positions where you can only
consider yourself like maybe
30 chance to win this end game it's not
very high because the drawing margin is
so large
but 30 isn't bad and you have basically
zero percent chance to lose so that's
also a plus
the issue is that I think if he plays F4
here and let's say take on F4 most
likely
or King E7 first but I think he'll
probably transpose Rook D4
gf4 Rook one takes F4
and I don't know if black plays H3 first
but black can also maybe try to jettison
that pawn like for example Rook
HD it comes to mind something like that
I don't think that white is taking on H4
because then take take and Rook to D2
comes out and I'm not sure that this is
leading anywhere good for white because
that a pawn will become very very
uh we'll run down the board very quickly
so
so the question for black is how do you
get rid of that H button or like force
white to take it and then get your Rook
active because after Rook 88 I think
white simply plays King to F2
some move like that
and black didn't actually gain anything
by by this Rook standoff in the center
because you don't want to take on D4 CD
forward correct whites uh the one
weakness in White's position
probably just be very bad end game for
black
the more you talk about this Fabi and
with f4 on the docket the more I really
believe that Ding has better than 30
winning chances I think this end game is
super tough well I guess 30 is a lot so
to be fair to uh your assessment there
but I just feel like this end game is
super super tough for black because
these pawns are sticking out it means
that they are going to be weaknesses in
the long term we talk about over
extension what does that term really
mean here it means that it's going to be
difficult for black to keep those pawns
defended which we see very directly in
the event of f4 The Rook capturing back
on F4 this will come to D4 the pawn H4
is just really under threat and if you
have to push it to H3 it's not going to
be much safer there we've talked about
variations like that just to put one
more on the board that in this type of
position with the Rook coming here and
H3 like even if you start with G4 this
Pawn on G4 is extra well-defended the
white king comes up quickly that pawn on
H3 if that one's lost the end game is
definitely going to be winning for white
yeah exactly that's why I was hesitating
to suggest H3 but maybe black should do
this and then try to get rook chc5 and
Rook A5 very quickly so I would I would
think Rook C8 here and white ideas
definitely to play King F2 G3 as you
mentioned but black is getting in time
with counter play as well so Rook C5
have King G3 Rook A5 and if Rook D2 Rook
A3 and that's a really annoying Rook
it's starting to attack pawns that are
difficult to comfortably defend because
you probably don't want to play Rooks F3
although you can
actually maybe you do want to because
the road goes to E3 and that's rather
good Square as well
otherwise you probably have to play
let's say Rook to C2 which I'm not sure
that you're
super thrilled about to put your Rook
from an open file into a completely
passive closed file on the other hand
white does have ideas here for example
to trade Bishops would be a good idea
for white I think that's mine I'd say to
get
yeah some Bishop Tab 3 D5 might be
not sure which is more I guess Bishop D5
is more logical
and
black is under pressure I mean yeah as
you said 30 if that's indeed like a
close to Accurate number is is a very
high chance of winning between between
two top players
yeah I mean I think you could speak this
way better than most people in the world
if you have 30 chance you have to make
the most of it I think that's what Jana
punished if we go back to the live
position he was disappointed about in
the previous game uh his winning chances
maybe weren't as high as 30 but he felt
like he had really good chances to press
on and it didn't happen but we did just
see F4 played by dingley Wren I mean he
should be confident about his position I
see the eval bar is still hovering close
enough towards the equality line but I
just feel like from a practical
standpoint Fabia I would not want to
play this from black I just don't really
see the proper defensive setup
yeah it's I don't think that black has
an easy solution here which is what you
want when you're defending
but the plus side for black is that he
has oceans of time and where these
things would really tend to go wrong is
when you're reach this kind of end game
more typically later into the game when
you're low on time but having reached it
with you know over an hour on his clock
if there is some sort of path to
relative equality then the honor has
more than enough time to find it I think
we'll probably quickly see King D7 or
gf4 followed by King E7
because I don't think black wants to
allow F5 like Rook D4 if you allow F5
then your Bishop which is so stable on
on E6 for example if black were to play
Rook a to G8
uh White certainly I don't think wants
to take on G5 I think white rather wants
to play F5 and then the bishop has to go
to a very very
um
unpleasant swear yeah Rook D4 played
quickly very logical
G takes a four plate absolutely
instantly also logical now Rook one
takes F4 will be played
quickly because the other Rook doesn't
attack the pawn if it's captured on F4
so you you probably take with that rule
what's he thinking about
he's probably thinking that Rook df4
does have ideas of maybe
Bishop to F3 D5 and then you attack F7
quickly
it's
I mean there are some
circumstances where you might as well
spend you know
spend a little bit of time to consider
it if it's logical or not
overcooking it like this seems like Rook
takes F4 he just played it he's not in
time trouble so that's the good news for
him but it felt like that would have
been the move he would have played in
bullet chess instantly
yeah I I think well he he did take
probably around 30 seconds so it wasn't
like a big time expenditure so you might
as well hesitate just to see
you know 30 seconds probably won't make
a big difference but
if there are sometimes those moments
where the most natural move isn't the
best and and it can sometimes make a big
difference so
H3 quick I'm surprised by Jan's
speediness like
so so quick
um
but it's logical what he's doing he
seems very confident
so you do you think that he maybe didn't
study in detail this end game but
considering the opening he played
considering that he was giving up a Pawn
on D6 getting into a queenless position
as such do you think that maybe he
actually has more experience with this
end game than we initially thought when
he slowed down
it's definitely possible he's seen that
seen something like this uh it's not out
of the question Lady it's not even out
of the question that he's seen
specifically his endgame that he has
analyzed it and that
uh he was just trying to recall exactly
the details the more likely thing I
think is that he's just doing yawn
things which is fine quickly because he
kind of has a feeling that they're the
right move and he doesn't want to
overthink it I was thinking about a
funny line here after G4
which is actually probably relevant like
Rook a to G8 came to mind
and King to F2 is the most obvious move
I was thinking about this crazy F5 I
mean it probably doesn't work but
GFI Rook G2
obviously doesn't work now seeing the
computer but King E3 work takes H2
and my idea was if fe6 there's Rook
takes E2
uh yeah probably instead of F6 Bishop F3
is is the winning move but this was an
idea King E2 H2 and
black will win a rook with that pawn
and amazingly that it's a draw because
it looks like White's up two pawns but
blackheads to win this Pawn on A2 and
that not only takes a pawn away but
protects that last Pawn on A7 and this
is enough for a draw because the pawns
are doubled here instead of split which
would be very helpful or winning attempt
so G4 has been played fobby I don't
think we are going to see The
Adventurous F5 just because well it
doesn't show it again just because there
was a win for a white in there somewhere
so takes takes I think Bishops have
three after Rook takes H2 oh that's so
nasty instead of just not eating a free
Bishop you can
bring your Bishop here yeah and you
probably just start to get checkmated
after like Bishop C8 F6
and your King has no we're good to run
to King F7 Bishop D5 and so on you know
F Pawn pushes you're getting attacked
viciously so
yeah he plays the most natural Rook C8
we're probably just heading for that
position that we saw King F2 Rook C5
King G3 Rook A5 because it's hard to
find deviations for either side
and I worked to D2 has kind of forced uh
because you need to hold on to it the a
pawn is much more important than the C
Pawn
because you don't want black to have an
outside pass Pawn which is just
barreling down the board then black will
start to get a better position you
really need to preserve your Pawn Knight
too
yeah A3 Rook C2 not beautiful but
yeah if if it holds the pawns together
it holds the pawns together and you came
up with multiple ideas for white right
to trade the Bishops I was actually
thinking rookie for rookie five Rook H5
at some moment to try to trade Rooks and
get an outside pass pawn it looks gross
for the pawn structure but it might also
be viable but either way King F2 is the
start of this type of variation and
yeah I mean I feel like dingly wrench
should be feeling good about his chances
and after game nine dingler was actually
asked uh to rate his own chances to take
the match on a scale of one to ten so
let's hear what he had to say
it had to be something to win the match
or to win next game
to win the match to win the match
um five
thank you
you saw the face of Jen right I saw some
some something from this side do you
have more questions
Bobby we heard dingler and answer the
question with A5 uh first of all are you
surprised that he answered the question
at all do you feel that the players they
should keep those answers to themselves
well I like his mysterious answer
because we don't know five out of what
so depending on what number he was
thinking of it could be super high
confidence or or general like average
confidence like I'm still in this 5 out
of ten got a 50 shot at this uh if it's
five out of five I mean that's
tremendous confidence whoops yeah it's
um
it was a funny moment from a press
conference
I did like the answer of five
and from Jan you know he gave a bit of a
face he probably was surprised because
objectively Jan is a pretty big favorite
right he is up a point with only five
games including this one to go so Jan
kind of uh he made a little face there
I've been like you sure you have a five
out of ten I'm not so certain myself
yeah we we saw that at the moment the
odds are estimated at 77.7 percent
which
we don't know exactly what the truth is
of course you know these things can
change daily and we've seen so many
swings back and forth if if ding
converts his advantage that he has today
and he does have some sort of advantage
probably not a decisive one but some
sort of Advantage then he'll be back to
a pure 50 50 and his five uh his predict
his confidence level of five will be
fully Justified
and
yeah you know Jana is playing this also
super confident I mean he's basically
like the last since G5 he has not taken
a single uh not a single move has he
thought for more than like 10 seconds I
think
yeah and I wonder every move has been
you know just bashed out instantly well
as you've said that could either be yawn
being young or Yan being in his
preparation or within uh the framework
of his preparation because this end game
this type of end game had to be foreseen
by him and his team that D6 Pawn was
available from an early stage and now
that we're here uh you know dingley Ren
very uh advantageous position just up a
pawn no risk whatsoever uh avitation
sent that from a psychological point of
view more so than an objective one uh
but how do you rate yawn as a Defender
because uh he has changed his style a
lot over recent years especially the
candidates so how would you rate yawn's
defensive tenacity
well he has an interesting defensive
style which is actually to Blitz
so he's not trying to some guys try to
calculate their way out of danger he's
more I wouldn't say the bluffing type he
doesn't like Bluff but he does try to
put that pressure on his opponent using
the time Factor
and it's a little bit unusual I don't
know so many guys who defend in this
manner
but it can be very effective I mean the
question is here
is he blitzing because he knows those
are good or because he feels the moves
are acceptable like those are those are
two options if he knows those are good
because he kind of just knows his
position
and yeah of course you should be
blitzing
um
but I have to say like the moves that he
came up with they are probably the best
move you can kind of the best moves you
can kind of feel that this is maybe the
direction that black should be playing
them because they're warned other very
logical options besides to get the Rook
to A5 and so with the last move that
dink played A4 his idea is that he wants
to meet Rook A5 with Bishop to D1
and then black cannot play Rook to A3 so
white Rooks remain active the downside
of this is that the H3 Pawn is going to
be difficult to attack
because the bishop on D1 can no longer
it no longer has the freedom to go to
f3d5 or to F1 attacking H3 it can only
stay there defensively
and
yeah I had a question for you because
after Rook A5 Bishop D1 it looks like
Bishop D7 goes right after that pawn
could we see like an exchange sacrifice
there where white takes all the pawns on
the board
yeah white could consider root takes F7
there
would black ever want to play Bishop D7
I really doubt it because you you also
do invite Rook after E4 and then you
probably just go back with your Bishop
right
so yeah I guess that's true but then you
you're happy to repeat moves but the you
know eval bar saying you're wasting time
Robert bad on you but I just I guess
what was thinking is there this exchange
sacrifice as well where the engine seems
to oh darn I thought it was there it
disagrees but I was just trying to see
if you could take all these pawns but I
guess the remaining pawns are so bad
that it's can't be worth it
yeah I would have on paper a huge
material leads right uh bishop and three
pawns maybe it's not huge but it's it's
considered a material lead but those
pawns fractured as they are and Rooks
especially when they have a lot of open
files they they really do Thrive so I
could probably play King to F6 Rook
takes B7 and then try to get that other
Rook active
uh maybe Rook to d8 here would be very
good because the bishop
where does it go to B3 do you really
want that you probably don't want that
too much and that that Rook is coming
into a lot of nasty squares for example
Bishop B3 liking like it's their Rook to
E5 and then two Works coming down
uh Rook D3 Rook D2 all sorts of ideas on
their cards and not really looking like
white just playing for a win here no
you'd need this bishop on D5 and then
you'd feel much better about your
position but of course and I feel like I
might win this game
that was my dream universe so Fabi uh
that's really out of the question but
Rook A5 Bishop D1 so if you can't pile
up pressure on this A4 Pawn I guess that
was my essential question is your Rook
really better off over there on A5 and
the bishop on D1 is kind of a heroic
piece it defends A4 and defends G4 at
the same time
yeah it's it's definitely a good piece
and then the question is I'll leave
can black do anything and can white do
anything if black can't do anything it's
it's not going to be a fun defensive
task
just by the nature of you know nobody
likes to sit around and wait for their
opponent to find an idea
um
but if I could do something let's say
Rook A5 Bishop Z1 I'm I'm considering
this move Rook to A6 I have a funny
little move but I I really want to get
that Rook active Rook B6 and so on
uh on the other hand uh it does feel
rather artificial and maybe C5 here is
very unpleasant so
probably not something that is uh likes
best bet
but definitely some ideas like this will
be
occurring to both players
and one of the big questions I think
that needs to be answered in this
position is what trades are good for the
players so we see the current framework
white is up a pawn double isolated pawns
and it looks like young does go Rook A5
we'll see Bishop D1 played quite quickly
because otherwise you're dropping your
A4 upon what would the point of A4 been
if not for Bishop D1 to follow uh but
yeah the big question is what pieces
would you trade if you were a dingly
render what do you want to see off the
board
oh I would love to see the Rooks off the
board if I was staying
because then you pick up the H Pawn and
you have a nice Bishop end game
and actually I would like to see any
trades with white
for example if I could
play King G3 here and take the Rooks on
F4 and A5 off the board I'm absolutely
thrilled with what because then black is
left with one passive rook and not one
active rook and white trucks are not
like they perform the same function
it works on D4 F4 they're both kind of
just defending the pawns on C4 and G4
they don't actually like one of them
does isn't needed so much so
Rooks on F4 and A5 traded off Bishop
traded off depending on the concrete
circumstances usually good for white and
as I say that it starts to feel like all
trades are good for white
and what about Pawn so I think you made
some really good points that Black's
Rook is Super Active over here Great
Piece White's Rooks doing the same task
defending along the fourth rank they're
on good at least a semi-open line the
file a fully open Line the D file but
they're not threatening anything so a
rook trade any Rook trade would be good
for white Bishop trade also good for
white in most these positions so what
about pawns which pawns for example F5
is available here what kind of Pawn
trades would be good for each side
the only Pawn Trend I can imagine
happening is the g4f Pawns of course
from like let's say in a vacuum
black trading the H Pawn for anything is
great for black just because that H1 is
a weakness and you would well I guess
you wouldn't want to trade it for the C4
Pawn probably but any other problem
besides that you probably are happy to
trade it for
so like h1's off the board black is
definitely not worse maybe it's starting
to get a bit better
and any queenside pawn trades are
probably good for white for example if
blackbirds to start considering A6 and
B5 it's not like the end of the world to
trade these pawns off for black but I
don't really see why you would ever want
to do it and you probably haven't been
very sad let's say king king yeah
uh generally speaking this is probably
not what black wants I would say that
like white could start with cb5 and then
Force black to Trail and A4 to be super
accurate
just to gain a bit of extra time
makes sense because Black's Pawn's not
going anywhere best move would be to
take next and as you said you gain a
little bit of time maybe King G3 or some
kind of include G3 yeah would be nice
but okay so that's so bad
because because you can attack the C3
Pawn but let's say in a vacuum
definitely uh should be a good trade for
white but just because C3 becomes such a
big weakness and
generally true Pawn trades uh
do you kind of ease the defensive side
defensive side's task
so this wouldn't be like a disaster
okay so but g4f is interesting
and I was going to ask you g for f is
one idea but can I just start throwing
this Pawn forward and you win it with
your Rook but I get your H Pawn so could
we see a g for H trade at some point
yeah we could so yeah this would open up
two possibilities one is G5 Rook G8 and
then maybe Rook to H4
and I don't know what this is because
I would much rather have let's have to
Rook G5 Rook H3 black would rather have
the F5 Plus on F7
just because it keeps the bishop 26 more
intact doesn't allow any checks to the
king
but this might not be a problem for
black I would be more worried about
other moves after F5
okay
for example the simple G takes R5
I think Bishop 5 is probably very bad
because we're T5 here
[Music]
uh just kind of disastrous I think to
allow the correction of the plot
structure yep
and if Rook takes F5 now we we saw that
trade that we were saying is generally
good for white the trader works so take
take
now you can't win the H3 Pawn very
easily but your Bishop has some Freedom
you can play Bishop to F3 and something
like that
and and Mike probably get a favorable
trip B6 is their C5 because if you take
I have Rook D5 and hit your bishop and
hit your one over here the question is
work f8 here uh you sneaky tactical
wizard you I was trying to take this
Pawn but Fabi is saying I'm gonna play
not Bishop E4 that would be a mistake
because of rookie five check but Bishop
G4 but I still have this check in rookie
three
yeah you you do but a lot of Trades are
happening a rookie through uh maybe like
working games are starting to although
it doesn't look super simple to me
is D6 Rook E3 and what's next is this
when the engine starts to get super
misleading where it's like okay of
course it's to draw and from as humans
we're like uh this looks very difficult
because this H3 Pawn is the target
White's already up upon things like that
yeah it's not simple I would think that
though if you have like an hour on your
clock you probably draw this without
serious issue I would even think maybe
black doesn't want to trade Bishops
maybe bishop to E6
and then you try to get Rook F4
go aggressive I like it yeah just
because the A and C pawns are rather
vulnerable especially the a pawn it
doesn't feel like white is going to have
enough to win this
I'm with you I'm with you so uh just to
kind of hammer the point home that F5 is
a very very big decision for Jan here
and once we went down the variations
with the help of the eval bar we see
that the evaluation remains about level
but if you try to step in the shoes of
Jana pamshi here I know it's difficult
to take back what we just saw but try to
erase that from your memory please uh F5
how difficult of a move is that to play
well F5 is is my sort of defensive style
I I'm trying to find the most concrete
option available
because I'd rather not just sit and wait
around and you know passive defense some
people
uh enjoy it more than others
but I would definitely be looking for
the Breakthrough as soon as possible
and
yeah Jan does not look concerned I mean
look at his body language
he's
I think he knows what the position is is
close to being uh level
it's of course it's clear that white is
the one pressing but he probably
realizes that the defensive resources
here are really vast
and he would have to really make a lot
of mistakes
to potentially lose this game
and yeah F5 I like it I like it well I
actually have a specific question that
we can analyze in a moment after F5 but
I think just a more overarching question
uh you say that there are many positions
that he can see or his overall
assessment is that it's level but do you
also think that they're gonna be many
positions some ghosts in his head
because we know with certainty what the
evaluation is he knows that black should
be within the range of a draw but
sometimes you see ghosts like that
position looks really uncomfortable so I
shouldn't go for it even though the
engine will say no that's a draw or
sometimes we think oh this position
looks pretty good because I'm active but
the engine refutes it pretty easily so
in this type of position is it more
likely that a player sees some ghosts
I think low on time certainly that's
that's a huge issue uh seeing ghosts
being scared for your position
especially when you kind of know it's a
draw
so you're like
there's this interesting psychological
phenomenon which is when you when you
kind of feel like it's a draw and the
draw is the correct is the deserved
result because the game has always been
under your control then you start to be
worried about every little thing because
you don't want to mess this up but if
for example you've been losing the whole
game
and then suddenly you're starting to get
chances to draw and you you realize that
you might not know if it's for sure a
draw but you're starting to get chances
then you don't see any ghosts because
everything suddenly looks good it's it's
the perspective of I was losing versus
I'm no longer losing and I recognize
that versus I was never losing and I
really don't want to be losing so let's
not
allow any chances let's play you know
pristine
no counter play nothing nothing to count
calculate that sort of defensive style
can lead you astray because very often
the way to to draw is not a way it it
has some rocky moments sometimes you'll
have to to calculate to to give away
control for a little bit
um it's rarely super super smooth so
that's why especially low on time
people can start to see ghosts a lot but
in his current time situation an hour on
the clock
okay he goes for a decent strategy
waiting
B6
and kind of move which can be a mistake
right no no keeps everything steady but
I think I understand why he played it
there's a specific variation that I was
actually about to ask you about and I
think this is why he started with B6 if
we can analyze quickly uh the move F5
which may be played in the near future
but F5 takes we discussed that the
bishop cannot take because Rook D5
sliding in between rook and Bishop would
force a trade and that would fix White's
Pawn structure but after it takes we see
a trade and what about C5 here that's
what I think Jan probably didn't like
the look of because now this Pawn on B7
can be attacked in a variety of ways H3
on a light Square still not the uh Best
Pawn in the world so probably do you
think this is what he was worried by
a curve this could have been a bit
annoying to him I'm wondering after Rook
see it Rook D Rook D5 is the idea I
would guess
yeah just uh defend actively try to get
a rookie and then yeah it's a bit
annoying because for example if you play
Bishop to E6 there's something they Rook
to E5 maybe and
some potential yeah this this loses on
the spot
so after Rook to E5 you kind of have to
give a check on a f8 and you don't want
to calculate the sort of stuff that's
that's for sure
right so yeah C5 could have been uh in
general or in that specific variation
something he was trying to avoid
makes sense so he starts with B6 so he
sort of keeps his structure keeps his
active Rook on A5 which patrols the
fifth Rank and puts pressure on A4 and
now the big question is well Fabi you'd
said this bishop trade somehow would be
great can't really move the bishop
because the A4 Pawn would fall so where
do White's chances come from I at first
thought that white had great winning
chances now I'm looking at this I'm like
I don't see a plan when I did a few
moves ago
yeah if we don't see a plan and I also
don't see one then I think we start with
King G3 take it from there
let's let's just imagine black plays
Rook to H7 here
Bishop to C2 Rook to h8
can we try to make this work
I thought you're going Bishop F5 yeah
but after Rook A4 I don't see it I don't
see the next move
I thought you were going to try to get a
pass Pawn here and go after this Pawn
if I could win the H3 Pawn quickly it's
yeah it's definitely very promising but
how do I win that H3 Pawn at all it
takes like three moves right
yeah at least
I was thinking of a past Pawn of your
own to work with so it just really looks
like a spicy ending
yeah no this does but uh Rook to A1 here
all right give me that oh Rook H4 and if
Rook G1 there's King H3
oh tricky tricky because if you take the
Kink takes and protects the pawn
so the engine is still well the problem
is for white the black has two pass
pawns as well so it's uh it's gonna be a
feisty one search for King H4 or if
E5 or A5 and yeah some sort of
uh mess of an end game no it certainly
will be a messy end game and you know
that dingley Ren right now he senses
that this is a big moment uh can he uh
bring his King up to G3 can he come up
with another plan it's these are the
questions swirling around his head and
while they do we're gonna head to a
short break but when returned it's more
from game 10 at the feed a world
championship 2023
foreign
[Music]
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book clubs
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and it make you more social
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
to the playing Hall in Astana Kazakhstan
you see ding Lee Wren the lone man on
the stage as his opponent yawned upon
she has stepped aside to the rest area
dingley Wren is on the clock and while
we were away we do have some great news
hey Tanya welcome back
Robert Guess Who's Back Becca again well
the physician definitely looks super
Shady Robert because when I left this
last it was a full-blown middle game
queens were on the board and it looked
like it was going to be a big fight with
anything that could happen and now I
look at the position a lot has happened
you've got to take me through what I
missed Robert
okay let's do a rewind for everybody who
also may have missed the action uh Tanya
back when White Castle kingside black
decided to throw the pawn forward with
H4 but one Pawn Ford was not enough the
pawn goes to G5 as well and it's now or
never if you want to win this Pawn on D6
ding Loren said I'm hungry I'm not
greedy but I will take a pawn when it's
given to me he snacks on it the Queens
do come off the board they're forced off
here and then we saw black played Bishop
E6 so we got into an end game where
black is a pawn down but White's Pawn
structure is in shambles on the queen
side ding strikes forward with F4 this
made perfect sense The Rook came back
and black could not allow the pawn to go
up to F5 that's why Yana popsy took an
F4 this Rook captures back because the
H4 Pawn is now a Target and here was the
big question black played the move H3
white pushed forward with G4 cementing
this Pawn on H3 as a long-term weakness
that black will have to defend but Jan
said I am not going to sit passively and
try to protect that pawn he goes forward
with his Rook up to C5 over to A5 and
then after the bishop defended we saw
the this is where the position remains
white can go forward with the King on G3
because Tanya Bob and I were talking
about this right before the break we
don't really see that many other ideas
or moves for ding besides bringing this
King forward wow I did miss a lot of the
action and Robert this end game that
you're pointing out the first thing that
comes to mind is this incredible
transfer of that Rook from A8 all the
way to A5 with a little Rook dance that
Yan did a really nice maneuver there to
make an inactive Rook Super Active by
making sure that that white Bishop on D1
is tied down to defend the A4 Pawn as
well as the G4 pawn and this means that
one Rook of yan the AJ Rook will defend
the H3 Pawn while the other one will put
pressure on White's weak Pawn structure
that you're pointing out as you said
that indeed White's plan looks like that
H3 Pawn is the weakness you need to get
to that with his own weaknesses the more
I look at this position I feel like
ding's gonna have a hard time getting to
that H3 Pawn probably one plan that
comes to mind is trying to push the Jeep
on further down you go G5 and you try to
trade on H4 and it's hard to achieve
that with again this Rook on A5 it's a
multi-purpose piece there
yeah I don't see how G5 is going to
happen anytime soon
so I'm sort of
struck by two things I I still like this
idea of F5 that
Robert was mentioning before the move B6
so if King G3 I'm still worried for
white that F5 will come on the board
that g takes a 5 Rook takes F5
and it feels like this trade of Pawns if
it doesn't have a tactical problem it
will be uh more beneficial for black
than for white
and if G5 instead of G takes F5
and after Rook to G8
again I don't mind this trade of Pawns
King takes H3 actually feels wrong
because after Rook G5 it feels like your
King on H3 simply getting stuck there
and it's just not a very good piece
and so I'm trying to stop F5 with the
move Bishop C2 instead of King G3 that's
what I'm thinking about right now I just
want to stop at five we'll take it from
there what to do next
I have some ideas I think with King G3
and putting a rook on e4 and trying to
play Bishop to B3 followed by C5
by Rook FTE Fourier Maybe
and then I'm trying to get I don't know
if Rook after Rook D4 but I'm trying to
get Bishop B3 into C5 maybe Rook D4 is
more useful for that reason in fact
and 12 minutes I think right now as
you're pointing out Bishop C2 to stop
Black's activity Fabi
uh does this does this give white any
chances to make progress or do you think
the most likely result will be a draw
even with this idea
well don't I think definitely the most
likely result is a draw that's just the
nature of this position is that black is
very very close to equality
because of the weakness of White's pawns
but if we can stop counter play if we
can force black to wait passively that's
already a good start
you don't win these positions in one
move it takes you'll take a full game of
grinding or outplaying your opponent to
do so so let's start with uh our first
task which is to stop the counter play
and the second task will be to try to
find a way forward so Bishop sees you I
like the idea if let's say black Waits
forever I just want to see if like we
can make things happen so let's say Rook
H6 Kings you through Rook h8 Rook D for
Rook H6 again
Rook to E3 Rook to h8
and now with Bishop to F1
yeah I'm starting to feel it or Rook at
five yeah that's what I just was coming
up with sorry to draw the arrows while
you're speaking but you know Bishop F5 I
didn't want to give my a pawn can I
start with Rook F5 of course you can't
take on F5 because I take with the pawn
winning your PIN bishop and if you go
Rook A6 what that is went from a very
active nice Rook to a pretty sad one and
now I can actually push this Pawn
forward to loosen up your defense of the
bishop 26. yeah I love this Rook of five
idea and and black should be avoiding it
and it might have even been a threat
already after Rook to E4 so so black
would have to deal with that immediately
so yeah let's start with Bishop C2
okay maybe we can start with Rook DTE
four in fact in that sense
okay so Rook dd4 threatening a weird
Rook F5
yeah I like this Rook of five idea it's
it's very sneaky the question is here
maybe Rook to d8 is just concretely a
little bit annoying
a computer does not think so but
it does look a bit annoying to me
yeah I like the look of this for black
because you do not want to see this Rook
get active as well the A4 Pawn is a bit
of an issue and Rook D2 is not fun to
see because black finally gets that
activity so I like what you're saying uh
Fabi just from a general standpoint
Bishop C2 sort of sitting on the
position and I have a question that's
more General than specific this position
um how often do you feel like games are
won by sitting on the position and
applying a little bit more pressure move
after Move versus taking immediate
action which can actually Force things
down to liquidation and thus a draw
I think unless it's like a Blitz game or
something games are like this are almost
never won by immediate action
especially in this type of position you
try anything immediately concrete yeah
you're not winning this game
um for example if you try to get that H
Pawn as quickly as possible I don't know
exactly how you do so but
uh that's not going to be the path
forward you need to take this super
patiently
so a game like this is going to be won
over the course of small improvements
which eventually leads to difficult
position and then eventually will lead
to a position where black has two hats
one is a draw and one is losing and then
your hope is at that moment your
opponent is under pressure and they they
choose the wrong choice that's usually
how it goes in case someone loses a
position like this
but it's never almost never won by some
sort of rush uh immediate action
make it slow you've got it
looking at these lines Bishop C2 really
seems to put a lot of pressure a
stopping Black from moving that pawn to
F5 forcing Jan to just hold the position
to just keep playing these small moves
while you make sure there's no activity
but once again I think for a lot of us
trying to get in G5 after F5 might seem
like a progress right Robert you want to
take away that H3 Pawn you want to try
to get your Rook over to H4 perhaps
offer a rook trade go down with that
Rook 287 if the Rook trade is Decline
and I just want to Deep dive a little
bit more into this to understand this a
bit more if white does try to take
action immediately as Robert that you
were implying here that these are two
different approaches so let's say we
were looking at the idea of marching up
with the King to G3 hitting that H3 Pawn
Bobby you mentioned F5 is the big plan
and then targeting the G5 pawn and if I
do push G5 Rook G8 now here taking with
the King just blocking that King on on
the edge file not a great great option
but can white instead here Robert of
taking that pawn immediately just slow
down a little bit and actually improve
The Rook to H4 and not rush with
grabbing that H3 Pawn I'm also looking
at that F4 Square for the king to March
ahead if you do grab that G5 Pawn is
this something that perhaps can give
white some chances here I'm always going
to pick up the H3 Pawn next
yeah it looks really interesting
actually because the Rook is under
attack and you need to defend your
seventh rank because an active Rook
could be a problem for black to deal
with but H3 is under attack I just get
the feeling that this position now
becomes a position with chances for both
sides a three results position uh
because white is taking some risks as
well by allowing a rook down to say G1
and the King up to F6 at some moment
then there's some activity that you're
gonna have to deal with uh that said in
the eval bar approved saying the
position is level it's some kind of
dynamic equality where black likely will
be a pawn down in these positions but
because of White's very ugly Pawn
structure on the queen side with double
isolated pawns and another isolated Pawn
to boot that should give black the
necessary comp compensation but yeah
it's a really interesting try Tanya
where white is just trying to get that
activity please allow my Rook into the
game but I ultimately think that there
will not be progress Beyond a couple
checks just because black position is
that sturdy wow it's move 27 and
kill for Ding and you Robert you're
approving of this line as something that
does give activity for both sides it
could change the Dynamics of this
position and of course the other
approach keeping everything under
control just stopping this F Pawn from
advancing it all with the move Bishop to
C2 and ding is clearly got these ideas
on his radar which is why he's in a
think tank right now but there's still a
bunch of moves to be made he needs to
keep he needs to be a little judicious
with his uh clock handling at the moment
but he's got 42 minutes and both these
players we've seen fantastic play by
them in the opening the middle game and
the end game and Bobby we had an
interesting conversation in chat and I
want to ask you first about this that if
you could pick a player to play the
world championship match against between
janapamnushi and dingler who would you
pick to play the match again
like who I would consider to be in uh
easier opponent personally
I mean it's just who your choice would
be I think that would be a smart thing
to do but it's probably hard to pick an
easier opponent but who would be who
would you prefer to play a match against
out of these two even their style um
I think I would probably pick to play
against ding
but I'm not exactly sure why like I
don't I don't think it would be a huge
difference in terms of difficulty who to
play against
I mean they're both super strong
and we see they're pretty evenly matched
like we see a slight lead by by young
but that's not because he's been
dominating the match or anything you
know these these slight differences in
score they can very often be
um explained by factors that happened in
the Heat of the Moment right not because
of some sort of overarching theme that
Ian is better or ding is better but just
because uh a lot of these things are
decided in the details I think I would
probably pick ding because
so back in the day I had a good score
against him
the last few years I really struggled
and and I would like to remedy that in a
match
and Jan I've played actually a lot less
against yon because he kind of reached
the top very top very Pinnacle chess a
bit after after ding did and after I did
so
we haven't played as much but we've
played a lot of very interesting games I
mean from the candidates last year we
played uh these first Wild game in
Italian like absolutely crazy game
and the second one was also some kind of
very short calculating flight we made
two draws and both draws were sort of a
disappointment because I had very
serious winning chances in both games
so
they would both be very interesting
players I think I would probably pick
ding but
I can't put like an exact reason why
just feels like
it's like I'd have more fun against
sting
stylistically do you think that you and
ding you know both of you super strong
in your calculation do you think you're
matched more stylistically and with Yan
there is a certain Clash of Styles as
well
uh yeah I think that if we're going to
try to isolate chestyles which I think
is difficult between strong players then
probably I match a bit more with ding in
terms of style
uh and a bit less so with yanhu is let's
say a very kind of intuitive player
uh and like traditionally calculation
has been one of my my strong assets and
also for ding but I think that my style
Jennifer
gonna go by the classical deficit show
style my style has changed a bit over
the years and I've definitely become a
bit more intuitive and a bit less of uh
a guy who's you know calculating
um fervently every move
he does play King G3 and actually I
think the reason why Bishop C2 was
rejected I think I saw the reason why
because there's actually very annoying
move after Bishop C2
and and that move is Rook to G8
the option to actually strike with F5
and Fabi you were mentioning that the
thought process behind the decision to
move up with the king is perhaps the
option that after the bishop move that
we were looking at black could have
stepped over with the Rook to G8
yeah and now King G3 is met by F5 in a
much more annoying version than in the
game and here white simply I don't think
has any chances for an advantage King H3
I can take on G4
I guess with the pawn followed by rotate
shape
and and probably white is not really
fighting for an advantage here
so Jan is just waiting or is he waiting
with Rook H6
yep
okay so Bishop C2 let's give it a shot
now
or does he want to it's just waiting I
guess yeah there's no other idea to this
move
but
okay Rook D to E4 I like it Rook F5 next
let's go
so King does the king have to move out
of the uh e file because I feel like
Rook F5 is such a strong threat because
The Bishop's pinned can you make some
kind of king move like King D7 yeah you
can but I'll play Rook to E3 now
and I don't see you having any active
ideas
but I do see some ideas for myself
so what if I just keep moving my Rook
around
because now you've taken pressure off
the a pawn so you gave me a little bit
of Freedom there
why do you do attack my C Pawn
so how do I respond to this idea I can
play Bishop I can trade Rooks but do I
want to Bishop takes a five
let's say I Rook takes a five I can
trade another pair of Rooks it's very
dangerous because now I'll have a past H
Pawn and you have only potentially in
the past eight one and you only have one
Rook that can deal with it so
uh might be a draw but it's not work C
rookie four
it's not like a hundred percent that
this is an easy draw for black I mean I
would say I would be very concerned
going into this end game
Bobby I just want you to know that our
chat they know you really well they also
picked ding as the opponent that you
would want to play against in a world
championship match well done on time
well in my I was thinking about this and
Robert it
unfortunately I don't see it happening
but in my dream dream world in some
alternate universe if I had to pick an
opponent I think I would go for ding as
well to play a match against simply
because I feel facing someone like yeah
I would be petrified and terrified he
has this such a strong intimidating
presence on the board which can be so
difficult to deal with Robert do you
think that's ever a factor for me it's a
big one
no I don't really think so because I
think if all these top players have
played a card Nakamura enough to know
that he's always making gestures making
faces and you just kind of ignore it
because honestly chess is a game you
have to be objective about and when you
start paying attention to all the
mannerisms and the irregularities
particularities of each person then
you're getting distracted from the chest
itself so I actually don't think for the
most part that the players are paying
too much mind to that kind of stuff I
think for Jan he does try to use it to
his Advantage I think at times it does
work to his Advantage but the best that
you can I mean you need to remain stoic
you need to focus on the chest Bobby I
think does a great job of that what he's
playing I I never really see him react
to his opponents
um you know their behavior but well
dingly run he made a quick move so I
think he's not bothered by whatever
Jan's doing either
that it's your idea what you mentioned
put the other we're on he's sliding with
the F Rook to E4 and I know just he
wants to push the D Rook one step ahead
and really offer that trade which Yan
has to avoid which would mean placing
the blackwork on A5 in a very
undesirable Square so same idea Fabi as
you mentioned earlier
yeah this contains the Throne of Rook D5
and I think black should prevent it
with King to F6 I guess
I guess you can play kingdom8 as well
but I don't think you want to elaborate
D5 because then as you said if you put
your Rook on A6 that's
you plus Kingdom f8 so was this idea of
Rook H6 he wanted to like king of it
without allowing Rook d8 check
I guess so that's super deep
but Rook fp4 wasn't even on our radar we
were thinking about DTE for and rooked
F5 when
when the king
oh maybe his idea was Rook DT for king
of f8 anyway in The Rook on H6 protects
the bishop on E6 Ah that's a really
clever Point by Bobby there that Rook
takes E6 would be hanging because the F
Pawn is pinned but the Rook is on H6
defending and there still is no G5
because the Rook on A5 covers that kind
of push now that actually is quite
clever I think this explains the Rook H6
idea because he was probably worried
about some either Rook somewhere to E4
ideas followed by Rook D5 or Rook F5 and
he really wants his King on f8
so he was singing Rook on H6 to Fantasy
E6 bishop and uh is no longer in the way
of any sort of Rook dhx so it's just a
multi-purpose Rook there right there's
no check here it's just a check
now how does ding continue this position
I really feel like the bishop belongs on
C2 but he has not moved it there yet
and his blacks can go into G7 it does
look pretty safe on G7 that is true
give a check and try to place his Rook
on another spot is there after giving a
check on diet do you think there is
another better place for the D4 Rook
that it could be headed to try to make
progress in this position it's of course
a very slow grind that and also you know
I keep reminding you of this but the
clock situation it's move 29 for ding
that's 12 more moves to go he's got 33
minutes on the clock how much of a
factor is the clock right now
well it's not a super high
um
calculation position yet
like the the weight of his decisions is
not so high it he knows that like as
long as he doesn't blunder anything it's
probably not going to be that
devaluation changes too much one way or
the other
so I wouldn't say the clock is a huge
Factor also he's not really risky but
you never know because once you get
closer to the time Patrol some some
complications suddenly begin you you do
want to have that extra time buffer even
if you don't see the complications
starving they they could at any moment
right
so yeah as you said Tanya Rook to d8
followed by Rook to B8 and B7 it's
definitely an option but
feels a bit artificial
could could be considered though for
sure
Bobby has that ever happened to you in
your chess career where in a Time
scramble you just psychologically it's
been so difficult and it's just gotten
worse to make a move
oh yeah I mean I've had time scrambles
usually time scribbles I can remember
have been not good ones
but I've had some good ones too I
remember once two thousand
eight I think I'm gonna say it was 2008
I was playing Simon agustein
uh who was the childhood coach of Magnus
Carlsen also was the top Norwegian
Grandmaster for a very long time and it
was without increment
and we stopped we were both blitzing out
we were down to like one minute I forget
how many was we had to make and we
stopped uh recording the moves because
once you're under five minutes you don't
really have to
but we didn't realize at some point
because the clock didn't immediately add
the time after 40 moves so we didn't
know which movie we were on
so we ended up continuing to Blitz split
splits and then suddenly
um one of us Flags
and so we can start the game it turns
out it's moved 47.
and my last move has been a horrific
blunder I was up a piece and I just like
in a panic with one second just like
tossed the piece away and uh it ended up
still being a draw because I was so
winning before I gave away a free piece
so we it turned into a draw but it was
it was at one of the craziest time
scramble that I've had the other one I
can remember is my uh 2015 slingfield
cup time scramble against Magnus Carlson
which like I see Robert here here
nodding you you remember that one it was
it was also not a good one for me I was
it was a very complex game
very double-edged and at some point I
was taking over the initiative
I had a big Advantage which was we were
making mistakes in time trouble so it
was kind of Shifting back and forth
uh but on someone I had a very very big
Advantage but it I got down to seconds
again we had no increment
and this time I knew that I was when
move 40 was but we both got down to
seconds we were just time scrambling and
in a panic I made a horrific blunder I
was about to lose my queen and then I
also ran out of time
so those are the two that immediately
popped to mind us
avoid time trouble that's all I could
say
that's what ding said right Robert in
water
inferences that the best option the best
solution is that you just start playing
fast but only if that was that simple
because there's always a payoff between
the amount of time you take and the
quality of the moves but also that is
directly proportionate but also you have
to be careful to have enough enough time
on the clock for those critical moments
and we did we we see ding here
playing the move Rook today coming up
with a check and now potentially after
the King goes to G7 and also let's point
out that the king must go to G7 if you
come back from where you left then that
would then allow white to fall back with
the rook and the plan that we've been
discussing all the way to D5 offering
that trade which is not good for black
he goes King G7 and now once again
expecting thing to take a bit of a think
here it's an important moment because
you need to decide where he wants to
place and what he wants to do with that
rip on the eighth rank one plan that
Fabi pointed out try to get it to the
seventh rank the D7 Square currently
controlled uh by the bishop he could
have gone with the Rook to B8 the Knight
square and then stepped it up to B7
instead he attacks the A7 Pawn he goes
for the move okay so still just slowly
keeping up the pressure keeping the
status quo as it is in the position but
asking Yan to continue playing and
defending this position looks like a
good strategy Robert
yeah it actually looks like a great
strategy because I was just thinking
what moves does black have here if you
get active with your Rook you have to
calculate what happens in the king takes
H3 and now all of a sudden white has
stolen that pawn will have an outside
passer that's a totally different type
of dynamic to this game if you want to
move this Rook from A5 move to C5 well
you're dropping the pawn A7 you don't
really want to give up that pawn for the
C4 Pawn even if black is still holding
there you are giving up a very healthy
Pawn for a double Pawn not the best
trade in the world if you move your
Bishop say to D7 that's the only safe
Square for it you allow this Rook to
slide up to E7 and maybe we're getting
into a territory where white can start
an attack so I just think that all of a
sudden young needs to be a bit careful
here he may still be within that drawing
territory but the challenges have
changed and that means he needs to
change his mindset with it
so I'm wondering Bishop to D7 I that
move feels critical to me I'm attacking
your Pawn
and uh how are you dealing with this
idea
you mentioned Rook to E7 but after
Bishop takes A4 I don't really see the
big deal I thought I had Bishop F3 but
then you're saying Bishop C6 because
you're Rook over here right
yeah if you could get Bishop G5 that
would start to look really dangerous
that's true but Bishop to C6 looks
pretty
pretty steady yeah and um I'm guessing
that this is position after let's say
Rook takes A7 is starting to go towards
a territory of just complete draw
yeah take everything take on F3 and Rook
C6
and it routes A4 but yeah it feels like
a draw
um
even probably B5 is a drone
you're right
and
yeah okay well I can still play this
after Rook to B4 I mean it's you can
still play this for a bit King G3
not the easiest draw in the world but
still no one that God would know is
within that drawing threshold I mean he
could probably see that he plays like
King G6 King H3 F5 here and it starts to
get oh wait what was that
did we Ponder with King G6
how
what in the world
so it takes F5 as you
apparently this is a good end game for
white
maybe just Rook B5 his work to be five
very strong yeah maybe I thought the
king would get active would take and now
Rook D6 Rook C5 is
is winning the other Pawn
all right working games are tough but I
feel like black had some much easier
moments uh earlier on in this variation
yeah it's it's true though but I think
it's a good illustration that you know
we think Rook end games a lot of them
are drawn that's what the Mantra is all
working games are drawn let's trade-off
pawns only one extra Pawn in a broken
game often not sufficient to win but
with pawns on both sides of the board
that gives white increased winning
chances because if we just highlight
that variation we're just looking at
very quickly that if you take on F5 and
the black king gets active this is a way
to not win the game because you're
allowing the black king to go up to try
to win this pawn and The Rook can
sacrifice itself for the H Pawn black
will make a draw however this Rook B5
move is very very important because now
when you trade the white king is just
going to run this way and if the black
king has to stay in front of this past
Pawn you're kind of caught in two
different directions and white is going
to win that race and C4 will drop so a
very interesting end game that we could
see in this position and Yan needs to
calculate deeply he can't just assume
it's a draw uh we made that mistake we
you know have the eval bar at our
disposal where we're yeah it should be
fine but I think for you on the palm
shahit before I'm playing with Bishop D7
and ending up to take this Pawn A4 you
need to be absolutely certain that this
will hold
I don't feel like this is oh sorry Tanya
no make your point Bobby
I I was just gonna say that I don't
think that ding's ideas to go for this
working game so that's so I'm wondering
what things idea might be after Bishop
t7 because I don't think that rookie 7
followed by rookie Rook end game would
be look too attractive to his eye
but what else would he have in mind
yeah
and it's a big question right if not
Bishop D7 the more I look at this
position more it's difficult to come up
with an alternative for yarn as well
Bishop D7 going into this end game with
the traits that you're pointing at is
not the it's not going to be super easy
to hold that end game but it is holdable
but if not it's sort of a difficult
moment to handle you can't step back
with your Rook on eight six let's just
point out you want to get rid of that
Rook on it with a trade on h8 that H3
Pawn you just highlight that pawn that
that's a big weakness here Robert a
trade on h8 and then you just end up
picking up the spawn on H3
and if you don't have that option the
other move would be in the current
position to start attacking the C4 Pawn
I'm just trying to avoid them with
Bishop D7 just to understand the
Alternatives in this current live both
that we have the Rook C5 after Rook
takes A7 now you can't pick up the C
Pawn with your Rook
well maybe you can go Rook C4 here and
try and offer The Rook trade as well or
is there some tactics with rookie 6
Bishop B3 this could get interesting
after Rook C4
over takes C3 would come with check oh I
think I think white can just trade Rooks
and then we mentioned at some point that
the trader pawns on the queen side is
just generally beneficial for white
because white C pawns are doubled so
getting rid of one of them is
uh it's less valuable Pawn in Black's a
pawn so here here white would look to
the future with confidence uh extra pawn
and no longer having double pawns and H3
still being weak so this is definitely
good but yeah I really feel like
there's one move on my radar and there
are no other moves Bishop D7 or I I
can't think of another logical move
yeah
only move on the board for Yan you
continue to keep the balance the way it
is and that's Fabio pointing out it's
the only one that makes sense to you
well it is a very direct line after
Bishop D7 and Yan in a seven minute
thing currently so he's trying to
evaluate that end game Robert what do
you think is Bishop D7 going to be the
move of choice for Yan uh simply because
hard to find an alternative
process of elimination sometimes makes
chess quite easy because every other
move that we've looked at has a real
problem to it uh this Rook on A5 needs
to defend A7 this Rook on H6 you don't
run a trade because it needs to defend
the H3 Pawn the only other move that
comes to my mind is Rook F6 but that
feels like playing with fire you are
giving up your H3 Pawn here and that
does give white some very legitimate
winning chances and dingley ren to his
credit in the candidates tournament he
won games that to most look kind of
unwinnable he beat young just of Duda
from the white side of a game that
looked quite level he beat Hikaru
Nakamura in the final round in a game
that doesn't look too dissimilar from
this one it was an ending where he just
pressed and pressed and pressed and
finally he was able to outlast Hikaru
who did make some mistakes along the way
so I feel like this is very much in a
ding Lorenz style to get to this kind of
ending he has some happy memories in and
games just like this it's the Magnus
Carl's person type of position where oh
it should be a draw it's going to be a
draw and then suddenly like wait this
looks really difficult so I do think
that Jana palmchi has plenty of work
left here he's playing confidently he
hasn't spent too much time throughout
the game he's up 20 minutes but some of
these decisions going forward will not
be as straightforward as the media
appears
um you can
fit and yeah and there's been a little
she saw him just getting up from his
chair right now and he can definitely
also sense that he needs to be a little
precise because all the pieces are in
the best possible position for black
it's hard to now not change the Dynamics
it's hard to just sit now and make a
waiting move with Black so you actually
have to take a decision and those are
the hardest moments and we speak so much
about the different styles of these
players and their approach to chess and
fairy Robert I want to ask you guys that
for Ding and for Yan if you had to
compare them to a champion of the past a
player from the past whose style would
be most comparable with ding and with
Yan a world champion of the past Robert
I'm going to start with you putting you
on a spot
well that was not cool at all a world
champion the past that I have to compare
ding to
um
I'll make it easier even if it's not a
world champion a perhaps any great
player from the Past who you feel good
I got it a great player that I can
compare dink to is dingly red done
did I just walk into that one that was
smooth I was slicker than the guy with
the thing on his eye well done Robert on
that
no seriously I mean just somebody who
you feel like their styles are match
because I was thinking about
for Yan I think at least in my head that
might be easier to to answer but do you
have one for for ding Fabi
I can't think of anyone I was going to
defer to Robert on this one
but now I'm I'm on the spot and it's not
an easy question uh
not an easy decision by Yan as well
back with the bishop
to Rook C5 played
Saved by the Bell there
you want to save me okay Rook C5 let's
let's analyze
oh it's too difficult I think what Bobby
I don't want to speak on your behalf but
what I'm guessing you're thinking is
that the players these days they're sort
of one style I think we typically look
back in time at the world champions
think of Mikhail tall oh this guy would
always sacrifice he was a vicious
attacker a calculator uh but that's kind
of where we leave him with which is not
fair to him either but these days the
players they do everything like dingley
Ren may have those grind them out
victories that I just mentioned in the
candidates but then you can think of
some great attacking games that he's had
and I feel like with the engines it's
hard to compare players of today with
players of the past just because of the
weapons at their disposal so
um I don't have an answer I will
continue to try to dwell on it and not
have my cop out with ding but I do think
Rook C5 here uh Rook takes A7 he will
not take with the Rook we saw that being
a bad option he'll take with the bishop
instead and try to go after the C3 Pawn
behind the C4 pawn and it's still a good
move we see the evaluation bar approved
so maybe Jan this is his style to take
the active defense rather than a passive
Rook end game
I think maybe he was worried about if we
go back to Bishop D7
I was just thinking
and obviously some moves are going to
start flowing in but
is this progress for doing now the fact
that he loses the double pawns And
Trades the C Pawn for the Apon I mean
that is actually very clear progress in
the position it might still be level
Arya balbar says nothing's wrong for
black but thing can perhaps start
feeling a little more hopeful about his
chances in this end game
I don't know if we're there yet because
after Bishop takes C4 he first has to
deal with the issue of how to defend C3
you can of course always put your Rook
on E3 but is that just going to be a
passive piece yawn doesn't seem overly
concerned and uh I'm wondering if maybe
what he was worried about
okay moves are coming in too fast though
so let's just keep it the live position
so I I guess the most natural move here
is Rook to E3 and he might even
play that quickly because
you you're getting ready for the bishop
to move it's it's gonna move so you
might as well defend the C3 Pawn
as soon as you can rather than wait for
black to attack it I don't see other
logical moves I mean
Bishops F3 unfortunately runs into maybe
bishop D5 but then there's Rook D5 so
maybe Bishop's F3 is some sort of tricky
little trap I guess you shouldn't Play
Bishop D5 you should maybe play Bishop
T6
just to show your point though Rook E5
is such a nasty idea because black wants
to win this Pawn but your Bishop is
threatened after Bishop F3 Rook C5 B
takes C5 King takes F3 I don't know how
the evaluation bar still stayed Center
there because yeah this is like shocking
isn't it this looks like I would have
thought winning for white I guess just
works at D6 and then if King moves on C4
and it's just very concrete black is
going after the C3 Pawn
oh Rook D6 is bad okay now I now I don't
understand tv4 is not the correct
response either so rookie seven rookie
seven is good ah
because if check the Rook blocks and if
the Rook comes here the white Rook goes
to E4 and C4 and then all your pawns are
weak from Black's perspective so as
blackplan Rook F6 followed by Rook to G6
like instead of Rook D6
it's the only other move which can come
to mind and then now Rook to D6 after
King G3
that is a very far hard to see from a
distance yeah I don't think that God
would ever go into this willingly he
would probably just played Bishop to E6
after Bishop to F3
and Rook D3 is forced and so that's why
I thought maybe it's more logical to
play it immediately
regardless of how they reach this
yeah
black
what's Black's next move
aren't we supposed to take a question
drops a piece on E6
just drops a piece so
okay so black has some questions to
answer here you don't really want to
play Rook C4
because the group can get kicked back at
will
Bishop to E2 you don't want to move your
Rook from H6 to F6 because it just
contains H3 so a rook on H6 is probably
just going to stay there
even giving up a pawn for free so you're
down two full pawns and yet it's still
completely level
but why
um
I don't know
oh yeah we're working for King G3
followed by rookie six yeah I was gonna
say I blended the same piece just to
finish the variation to show that uh you
know I make the same blunders even I
don't learn from the lessons that I was
trying to teach me Rook takes E6 once
again would be a free piece so it's not
too difficult the blunder John will not
do it but for me I'm blundering all the
time
wow every day I'm wondering our chat is
actually informing us I love it
that this game
this game I'm sure what engine evaluates
that but we've seen the eval bar stick
to it so it's kind of believable well
that's what happens when you got the
world number two playing against the
world number three at such a junction in
the world championship dingler and
they're reaching out and he decides
instead to sidestep with a rook on A7
which actually looked like a very well
placed beast and brings it to double up
with the rookon E on the E line is that
a move that surprises you because I'm
trying to understand what good things
idea be with this uh how does this help
him in the position does he want to go
rookie five and start offering a rook
trade
you have a bishop to E6 is The Logical
continuation for white
so strange looking move
I was kind of briefly thinking maybe the
idea was to play C4 but then after
Bishop takes E4 I want to see what you
gain
um
I mean the point of C4 is a rook C4
there's Rook seven takes E6 winning a
piece
but Bishop takes you for it yeah it
loses on the swamp move Bishop C4 what's
the point
variation super nice
what is ding's idea
after Bishop E6
does he just want rookie three but he
was worried about something somewhere
yes a big big question right I mean such
a mysterious move
maybe it doesn't matter where the Rook
is and he's just like okay I'll play a
move
[Laughter]
it's a good you know thought ads
whatever this will be okay
how to make moves and moves in the world
championship Fabi
I think so well it could be it could be
a type of position where basically a lot
of moves are pretty equivalent because
uh White doesn't really have a way to
improve so easily and so
he didn't see much of a difference
between Bishop F3 rookie three rookie
seven I get it I think I understand Fabi
I think I understand why he did this so
uh Bishop D5
you have to go rookie three because this
pawns hang with check
and now after Rook C6 over here these
Rooks are protected so Bishop F3 comes
to mind where you can't take on C3
because D5 is hanging and if you take on
F3 Rook takes F3 this looks like a
problem in two different directions
but then why didn't he play Bishop O3
first
don't have an answer to that question
and the funny thing is that all the
moves we make they don't change the
valuation we've made we've gone through
like
three different lines and the bar has
stayed completely level so it feels like
maybe it's just one of those positions
which is kind of
equal in a varied variety of ways this
doesn't look equal though two of Black's
pawns are under attack Black's already
down one so at best black will be down
upon the Rook end game and I think this
is where the eval bar gets misleading
where white will be up a pawn and with
best defense black will make a draw but
that defense may be increasingly
difficult as we get into certain end
games I think this one uh maybe does
make sense Rook F6 you have to save this
Pawn in F7 if we see a series of Trades
here and The Rook drops back okay black
can get active with Rook a rook C4 take
this Pawn in exchange for the H3 pawn
and I get why that's a draw but it's
still some work to do for young
yeah it's it's a draw like yesterday was
a draw
um it's a draw which we'll yeah we'll be
here for a while
while the the players prove the draw so
after rookie seven probably that's a
really interesting point you make about
what we witnessed yesterday and the kind
of action that we're seeing today right
the first half of the match we barely
saw an end game arrive we did in one
game but one side was clearly better
already but it feels like the pace has
slowed down a little bit compared to the
first half of the match which had so
many sort of back and forth between the
players and these big critical moments
and one was winning and then something
was missed and then the other player one
of them had the chance but now it's a
different narrative how do you explain
that like from your experience at the at
a match why does this shift happen
closer to the finish line
yeah I can I can explain with with my
experience that the players have seen
the commentary teams
for chess.com they know who's
commentating and you know they know how
much Anish loves draws
so they didn't want to give him what he
likes they wanted okay well Annie's just
commentating today we gotta
we gotta play as sharp as possible okay
let's let's make some blunders too then
once I get on they're like okay
let's quiet it down now let's let's make
some some you know
some 100 accuracy games
so Fabi you think that's the only reason
no I I okay so seriously I do think that
you have like Trends in the match
so sometimes you have
um some periods which are kind of wild
and both players are a bit unsettled and
uh
you know you have some wins some losses
psychologically there's some instability
there and then at some point this quiet
sound and you have the stability comes
back so yesterday and today this was
like a period of stability and it's uh
was right before it was preceded by uh
two completely Wild games one which
somehow I didn't draw but a draw was
anything but likely in that game and one
which was wild and ended in a completely
unexpected result a decisive result but
not the one that we thought might happen
so
I think we might see this also in the
last few games we might see some
stability or some instability and we
don't know but these things tend to tend
to come in waves
although definitely
seem there are two two players to get an
advantage so Jan keeping it under
control but it's ding who's trailing the
mat so sooner or later he needs to try
to create he needs to create those
chances and maximize them so risks will
happen for now a decision has been taken
by Yan and another move that was not on
our radar while looking at options yeah
she just lets go of the H3 Pawn he says
you can take it and perhaps the reason
for that is that there is a check coming
in with that Bishop from C4 to F1 C3 is
a weakness so Yan is eyeing the C3
weakness letting go of the H3 weakness
what do you make of this move Rook C6
quite an interesting tribe Ian here
yeah it's the point is of King H3 I
think just Bishop to E6 followed by Rook
text C3
and he's happy to get rid of that week
eight one that was doomed basically to
fall off the board sooner or later
during this game but he gets the C3 Pawn
The Rook becomes active the A4 Pawn
becomes a weakness White's best will
probably be that he gets two against one
which
is a draw right the H and G against the
F pawns with or without Bishops will be
a draw
but that's White's best case scenario I
think after the trade of H and C points
because it's also very likely that
White's Bishop which is so passive gets
harassed and white won't even be able to
hold on to that A4 Pawn
Bobby is there a reason that after King
history you mentioned Bishop E6 hitting
C3 and not the direct check on F1
I don't like the bishop on F1 but it
might not be bad either Bishop won King
G3 Rook C3 Rook E3 I don't know I I'd
rather keep the F7 Pawn securely
defended and my Bishop there rather than
uh
yeah I start to feel like
this is a bit less Pleasant just because
the bishop 1 F1 is out of the game
so I I'd either think Bishop D5 or
Bishop B6 I don't know which move I like
the fish one E6 because it's so stable
there but certainly Bishop D5 is also
not a bad move
yeah all right yeah
that's rabbit and we see a little shift
here both players playing a little
dynamically trading pawns on both sides
and getting rid of their weaknesses but
it does mean more liquidation and it
means closer to perhaps saving this game
with the black pieces for Ayana Rook C6
uh the big question for now for ding is
does he trade off the C3 weakness for
that H3 Pawn or will he find a way to
keep the tension going and we see there
in the playing Hall thing currently in a
think tank Jan has a left chair and we
will use this moment to go into a break
and we'll be back with more end game
action from game 10 of the world
championship match
this right here is how I use chessable
and why I've been using it for a long
time I mean if you look up here I
actually have my streak it says
1231 days right you're gonna forget a
lot of the things that are in the book
Joshua came around when I got unjustable
it's literally I was already doing that
so this is now a game changer because I
can do it faster it's online it's in
front of me all of my books are here if
they're gonna be folders now so I can
categorize my white black and all
tactics in game but I literally have
everything in one area as you see I'm
scrolling here this is what I like to so
they're like how many adjustable books
you got I'm like all of them how are you
accessible is actually I do a lot for
the opening training I do tactics on
here I do calculation I do in-game I do
everything but the database all my
training on here all the time adjustable
is the way this is why I like to use
stressful it actually helped me I
remember even online I was only like
tapping out at 23.50 almost 2400 and and
Blitz and bullet my chest com is 26 with
a high of 27.74 on bullet and I blame
all of this if like success really it's
just working on chessable just being
honest with you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
and still in the tank on a move 33 he is
thinking how he can make his chances how
he can really try to put pressure in
this end game which looks like it's
inching closer to the draw as we do find
more pawns being traded off on the board
it is a big moment for thing this is his
one of his three whites in the final
five games and while in this world
championship so far Yana Pam Nashi has
struggled a little bit with the black
pieces with this one Robert he managed
to equalize without too much trouble
taking Dynamic decisions out of the
opening if we think about the opening
that we had with King f8 he was precise
and he managed to get out of it without
any problem
yeah even when the positions started to
look a bit scary he just continued his
preparation he continued playing good
moves like G5 that was a really a good
one by him it seemed and I think for
dingley ran he was hoping this end game
would lead to an advantage but there
isn't much of one to speak of the
advantage lies in that one extra Pawn
come on you know we still got this over
here that one extra little guy uh but
that one Pawn doesn't seem to be enough
it's an equal position according to the
evaluation bar Jana Pomchi has the
necessary counter play he has a huge
lead on the clock he's feeling confident
and why wouldn't he be at this point if
he draws this game with the black pieces
only four games will remain in this
world championship
yeah I think that we are looking at a
position where he's going to have to
press for a while it's just the
tournament situation dictates and I'm
wondering if maybe he can
because he doesn't want that Rook locked
out of the game on E7 so he might try
Rook 7 to E5
and my worry here is that
what's very likely is okay the H Pawn is
falling off the board and I think the C
Pawn is not long for this world either
and then the A and B pawns will have a
very strong tendency to trade themselves
off and so will the Bishops and then
we're going to be left with an h g
against F Pawn Rook end game which is a
draw
and white can try a little bit but
but yeah your winning chances are
against a strong player are basically
under one percent
so
the question is can you try to keep the
A and B pawns off the board like let's
let's have a look at Rook 70 E5 for a
little bit
I'm going to ask you about a line which
you're gonna I'm sure there's a ref
addition to it but I'm gonna bring it up
anyway after rookie five Robert what if
black just straight and is Bishop B3
completely nuts or is it a possibility
well he just played rookie five and we
might see this and I was I was thinking
the same exact thing Bishop B3 offering
a free Bishop so it would appear but if
the Rook takes C to recheck the problem
for white is the king is under attack
and this bishop will be won now maybe
ding had the idea that Fabiano was
mentioning with Rook to B5 you cannot
take this Rook you this is going to be a
bad bad bad losing situation you'll lose
the H Pawn and now we will see the pawn
promote instead black will play Rook A3
and after Rook B6 Rook A4 King H3 this
is exactly what five inner was talking
about rook in two pawns for White
against rook and one Pawn for black but
we see the eval bar we know the players
understand this theoretically drawn
position you don't need deboretsky's end
game manual to hold this
so but that's why
no I think I think that you would draw
that pretty effortlessly Tanya
and uh
targeted on E5 and Jan shakes his head
but takes no time at all to make this
move Bishop B3 on the board so after
this little tactic the Bishops will be
traded off and Fabi the ending that you
were talking about we might have that
soon yeah that's that's coming on the
board white cannot really afford not to
trade because then the A4 Pawn Falls so
he takes on B3 Rook C3 forced King to H4
the most logical Square for the king
instantly played Rook takes B3
I think
it doesn't really change so much what a
wide place here but probably Brook to B5
as Robert mentioned
but all roads lead to Rome at this point
review if I've played Rook to A3
absolutely Force otherwise I think black
will lose this game if not for that move
I think he'll try to Rook to B4 here
because he can always get that two
against one oh okay he takes immediately
before it wouldn't change anything
because he could always take on B6 but
you go straight forward
and we will see this I I don't think
that they will take too long to play
this one out
um so yeah that was that was going to be
my next question to you Fabi the big
Eternal question how much is ding gonna
push this one how much is he going to
try how Elementary is this for Yan
I don't think he'll look he'll try too
hard so the interesting thing is uh and
I promise came up a lot but Jan has won
a two against one rook in game against
the top level Grandmaster in a classical
game
uh do you guys oh he's he's immediately
going for it this is going to be an
instant role yeah but do you guys know
which game I'm referring to
Beyond winning two
was it against you or something no no no
I wouldn't have brought that up
Tanya you might have actually were you
there it was the 2017 London chess
classic
[Music]
wow what was it two of us is one same
side
it was against Mickey Adams
I don't remember which round but it was
early on the event and it wasn't H and G
against f it was
um he was with the black pieces I think
he had F and E against G
but here we trade off the last Pawn why
does one Pawn left
yes wow why would be winning
this position if stalemate was a win and
white would win this position but
unfortunately still made as a drone
and ultip.h pawn was on the Jeep on the
G file instead that would be winning on
G2 but instead The Rook Pawn is known to
be a draw and think that with a smile
gives it up he knows there's no trying
in this one a hard-fought battle but
yeah saves the game with the black
pieces he there was never in too much
trouble today which means that he is one
game closer
with a one point lead to the world
championship title thing still has to
win a game to equalize the match uh
Robert you think this is a result is
pleased with of course he had the black
pieces so drawing the game is great for
him there are only four games now
remaining in this world champion and
ding just stormed off he didn't seem you
know super angry or anything but
typically the players they talk for a
little bit at the board even when a draw
was reached so I feel like for ding he
recognized that this was a missed
opportunity and Jana palmchi came very
well prepared
yeah a missed opportunity and it just
felt like ding never really got a
position to push out of the opening uh
Bobby do you think this was a a failed
opening approach by ding at least in
this game considering that how how
easily Yan equalized yeah I think
overall we already felt it from the
start after the move Bishop C5 we felt
like ding would find it difficult
uh or the later Bishop C5
that thing that Ding would find it
difficult to refute Jan's opening
preparation on his own over the board
and it was just a confident draw from
Young I mean he was slightly worse
throughout the game
but he was never in real danger we never
felt like
we never felt that feeling that you got
like oh this guy's gonna lose now he was
he was pretty confident throughout
playing quickly playing well it was as
as was already noted 100 accuracy game a
perfect game from both sides
but sometimes to win games you don't
need to play a perfect game you need to
play a messy game where you're making
mistakes but your opponents also making
mistakes and there's some craziness
happening rather than this where your
opponent knows what to do uh has plenty
of time on the clock everything
very confident very important result for
yesterday
yeah and this decision to play King f8
we were highlighting it during the game
I think this was a big moment any other
move would have been terrible for black
if you Castle there was Bishop H6 a very
known Motif where you can't capture the
bishop it is pinned to this King back
here and if you push the pawn that's the
only way to stop Checkmate you lose a
rook for a bishop so uh G6 is the
alternative would have opened the dark
squares that would not have been good
and I think the critical moment we were
analyzing a lot during this game but
this Pawn on D6 could have been captured
at many moments but here the decision to
play G5 by Yan a great show of opening
preparation and then from ding after
take on D6 Pawn takes back Bobby maybe
at this point if the game were to be
replayed a move like Bishop E3 or Bishop
C1 perhaps that was a better choice when
you need to win
yeah I think if he was given this moment
again knowing that Bishop takes E6
although objectively probably the you
know the engine move
probably not leading to a win that
keeping more pieces on the board keeping
Queens on the board with Bishop B3 it's
still equal like Black is Black is not
objectively worse here but you could
give this a shot maybe practically it
would be a bit more unpleasant for Eon
to play against
yeah but instead we saw the everything
come off here and white is better
there's no doubt about that white is up
a pawn we saw this defense F4 a very
good move because when we got to this
position all of a sudden there was
pressure against this H4 Pawn but Jan he
had this all worked out and after H3
even though that pawn looks like it's
wandered a bit too far I think he found
that everything wasn't so bad after all
yeah this end game is definitely better
for white but Dion was very confident he
played his next few moves pretty much
instantly as though it was a bullet game
almost Rook to C8 came
The Rook maneuvering its way to a very
active file
and ding in an effort to restrict that
Rook played A4 and Bishop to D1 but look
at all those pawns on light squares
being targeted by Black's Bishop you
have a feeling like black has a lot of
compensation here for the pawn
yeah for sure and after this uh you know
we were looking at a lot of different
lines but Jan left no doubt rerouting
his King and then at this point he
traded everything off in nice fashion
Rook C6 rookie five and then this shot
Bishop B3 really wonderful tactical
awareness from Beyond apology uh hitting
this bishop once the bishop was captured
on B3 thank you for the free piece well
thank you right back here comes the rook
in and we saw everything get swapped off
and by the way this was a great move we
glossed over it just because uh we're
getting to the end of the game but F5
just fg5 has played The Rook slides the
G4 thank you very much for this Pawn
that's an immediate draw and after Pawn
takes Pawn we saw The Rook come to F4
and there's no way for white to win Rook
B5 King F6 and we saw the Swap and we
know H pawns Rook pawns are not great in
these kind of end games when the king is
in front of it
loved how Yan actually sold all the end
game problems in that one instant with
the last move F5 that you were pointing
at is just such a professional approach
to not give any chances to close down
the game immediately and with that we
get our third draw in a row and we see
in Astana yeah
are ready for the press conference let's
head over to the players
ready
welcome everyone at the press conference
of the feeder World Chess Championship
match between
today we had round 10 and the game ended
in a draw now the current score is five
and a half to four and a half in favor
of Jana publisher my first question
would be to ding Loren today are you
satisfied with how the English opening
went for you in this game and if you are
also a word of the fact that Johanna
publisher played this very opening
himself at the title Tuesday
I guess Bishop A5 is the main line yeah
I I know game he played against arunian
and some years ago and he wins with
very in very accurate very powerful play
but C5 was came as a totally surprise to
me I have to figure out
the idea after during the game
um
yeah all right so
uh actually I had some advantages
uh at that point at one point I'm
wondering if I could
retrieve the bishop instead of taking on
D6 but uh
I didn't know if it's possible to go
back to Bishop but maybe it's not
possible maybe it's just a very bad move
so I played the nature move and I guess
he defends quite well so I didn't have
so many chances in that game
right um
[Music]
you played this as I mentioned you
played this very position at the title
Tuesday some years ago were you happy to
see
today that this happened in this match
this position
yeah well it's
the cold line is it's quite interesting
quite I'd say in case of
uh Bishop B4 instead of Bishop C5 it's
quite quite an equal position but it's
it's nice yes so white can uh play on
yeah has different plans and Bishop C5
is known to be more forced
and this bishop before BC uh this bj63
bishop C5 off yeah I played myself
against uh I can't recall what was the
player but I think some International
master
Carlos Jose Gabriel yeah correct
uh yeah and I got like lost three whites
after like three months already or
something yes so I I thought it's quite
quite a nice line and uh
I think it was uh already for quite some
time
I mean this idea Bishop C5 because I
mean objectively it looks a little bit
scary but uh
I wouldn't say
I mean
probably like if you go for first time
forcing lines yeah
uh then
yeah you take some extra risk but as far
as I know there is not so much what I
can do here um perhaps instead of
many many different editions of of this
end game
uh capturing like winning the the pawn
but the structure is so poor I wasn't
quite sure about if I should have played
H3 uh because the tree is double-edged
so probably uh I don't know something
like group C8 would be more smart
or maybe I don't know even even rook d8
and then Rook D6 uh just give away H4
Pawn but uh but get an active Rook
instead but somehow I thought that it
should should be all right yeah and then
I think it's basically a fortress yes so
I'm not sure if white can achieve
something so uh the only idea is like to
play Rook D5 or something yeah with my
king is only seven I'll trade blood
Square Bishops uh but I think it's very
nice for grouping with making on G7
um
it feels like uh black is in time like
yes or might have so many weaknesses and
H3 is not easy to capture
yeah we're all I think uh was it was a
decent game for me right and can we
assume that this decision that you
played G5 and you sort of forced to go
the actions to go to the end game is
based off the current situation on the
score of the match as you are leading or
would you play something more like H3 if
you were interested in must win
situation uh well I'm not I'm for now
I'm not in the Mastermind situation yeah
first of all and then I think I was just
trying to like to follow my my analysis
I'm not sure if I if I managed to but I
think I have seen this
I mean I had like some
something similar I think in my files
this F4 move and uh yeah so I think I
mean of course like black can play on
like with h3o some I don't know Samos
instead of G5 but uh
I guess it becomes like pretty much
double legit and uh
um yeah normally once black managed to
reach this end game
should be should be fine
thank you my last question to Ding and
then I will give the floor to press
um you mentioned that Bishop C5 was a
bit of surprise and there was like two
moments when you spend most of the time
on the clock that was when you played
Queen to G3 another was Bishop B Bishop
B2 can you please tell us what were the
possibilities that you were considering
in that position
well after Bishop C5
uh yes I only consider Bishop couldn't
just or any other move like Bishop D3
but it's
not uh didn't have a idea behind it and
couldn't just say but he'll move king of
Fate again surprised me I was expecting
G6 so I have to think again
to see what will be his answer after
Bishop E2 D6 Bishop 4. yeah I somehow I
expect the H5 idea if I go H4 then he
can probably Bishop at G4 at some point
later and then Rook here it's a very
quick develop
so at that point I decided to Castle to
let him to play H4
right all right thank you very much we
have the question from the Press please
go ahead uh
good afternoon good evening dear
colleagues dear guests uh yeah the
question is to you
were you surprised by your opponent
choosing this line and after the move
Bishop C5
were you surprised that your opponent
fell into thinking
uh
look s uh
negro
subscribe
[Music]
mm-hmm
actually this option was frequently used
and also I think by my opponent
and the move Bishop C5
well it's not so
actually it is rare on the high level
games
but this move I think was a good one and
it was a good trial to forsify the game
and to move it forward
yeah so I actually I'm not I wasn't so
so much surprised okay thank you very
much next question launcher please
a question for each one
forbidden after the previous game you
say that your level of self-confidence
regarding the winner of this match was
about five counting from one to ten my
question is if this game has changed
something on that sense and for Ian Mr
philatov President of the Russian trans
Federation said few days ago that you
looked as a monkey with a hand grenade
as this comment sounds really very
striking I guess for everybody I wonder
if you have some comment on that
thank you very much for the for the
questions
I assume that we will go first with the
thing
to answer the question
oh yeah it's
today I drew another white game
so it means
there are
only four games left
I need to at least
score one wins
to
to level the score
and
yes
become quite normal like there are three
draws
in the three drones
okay there the tournament still not
finished yet
so okay we still have four games left I
wouldn't say I was how much confidence
am I now I didn't consider that
let's smile
s thank you very much thank you very
much I think and now yeah
um thank you for a good question as
usual
uh but I guess
I don't really want to elaborate on on
this yeah so
okay okay thank you
do we have more questions from press
place
um having sharp just magazine car
Germany my question is
[Music]
um
my client asked three days ago
um thing about the trainings games on
leeches and chess.com
how did this information
um influenced your match strategy
thank you for a question I wouldn't say
it
influence it like too much
uh I guess yeah my team like took a look
but
I wouldn't say like it should be as
hyped as it actually
as as it actually is yeah so I guess
yeah
I'm still like
more or less doing what I supposed to do
uh or whatever I was going to do yeah so
let's didn't change it too much I think
thank you very much for the answer and
we have more question in the Press
please
[Music]
young the question is to you please
could you tell us how do you spend your
days off
maybe you spent them somehow differently
maybe you spend them walking around more
or maybe taking a rest more so please
ask tell us more about it
um
option
is
so actually I will repeat again so there
is nothing special
I will try to rest more but I don't
forget about preparation
so the day off means it's a day off so I
try to sleep a little bit more maybe
take a little bit more walk but still I
prepare anyway
and do we have more questions
yeah please go ahead commentary team
hi it's a question for ding um when you
took on D6 you went for the end game
like how seriously did you look at like
retreating the bishop to E3 and what
were you thinking there
yeah I'm thinking Bishop is through a
little bit
but suddenly I saw after take on D6 I
can play F4 afterwards so I decided to
simplify the position I believe I have
some chances in the end game but maybe
not so too much
thank you please question
actually I have the same question for
Dean how do you spend your rest days and
maybe your schedule just changed
since the beginning of the match
the rest day I go for some walk and
spend more time to rest to sleep
also just with my friends
and yeah something like this
thank you very much for the for the
answers I think now it's time for the
Twitter segment and Jesse will bring the
questions from the audience please Jesse
Jesse February here
the first question is from mads you are
both a great inspiration for young
people around the world
that love chess could you talk about
what your fascination about the game was
when you were young
let's go first down with you
oh thank you for the question
um I guess
uh that I was like
and then I just like learned to play and
learned let's say to to read so also I
could I could read some chess chess
books
uh I was really fond of replaying some
games from these books and are seeking
for some sort of Harmony
uh like in between the pieces yeah so
that was like uh sort of a favorite part
until some certain age
advice
um we will repeat the question please
all right so basically I said that both
of you are a great inspiration for young
people who play chess what was your
fascination about the game when you were
young
when I was young yes
um I followed many live games
so I
spent some time starting them so yeah
solve some tactic puzzles
all right thank you best blunder for
both dang and Yan you're playing the
grand chess tour in Romania just five
days after the match are you not wanting
to take a break after the grueling match
at all
I guess
uh I surely I will think about this
question but right after the mission
thank you and think what about you
yeah it's not something to consider
right now
right
fair enough do we have more questions
from Twitter yes from shagnik
has been involved in such an intense
one-on-one match affected your opinion
of your opponent in any way
this is the question to both players
please we go with the young yeah sorry
could you repeat please sure
has being involved in such an intense
match
affected your opinion of your opponent
uh
frankly I don't know
okay whatever
yeah it will play between we both of us
so it could be
influenced by both of us
all right I have one more question from
Yara
aside from the world championship what
are some of your longer term goals in
your career
yeah and let's go with you first
um I guess ask me in a week or something
okay we'll keep that in mind what about
you think
long-term goals long-term goals no yeah
thank you very much Jesse for the
questions do we have more questions in
press
well I do have one last question to both
players as the match is getting very
close to the end it is
probably very hard to keep it the energy
level up
so in your preparation before and during
March do you give attention to the
physical preparation
perhaps you keep certain training regime
or some sort of diets also during the um
match Yan please
yeah absolutely but uh
out of there some experience from from
the previous match I
uh you know I made some corrections and
uh
yeah surely you have like give up the
schedule and
which I recall is Diet here but in some
parts yes also this and also don't
forget about some physical activity
uh but yeah like I think it's uh
uh it's it's not the same for for
everyone yes so I like I can't say like
there is there is a standards you should
you should seek and try to
try to follow
right and to compare the world
championship previous world championship
match and now if we if you can give us
the the example of your physical
preparation what you have done earlier
previous one and what you are doing now
what's the change yeah it was it was so
long ago
okay um
and what about you doing
um what is how the physical preparation
and the diet looks in your case
some soccer or basketball like yo-yo
which was like what I like to do in
general also I I
run a little bit which is
not so fun but I
uh
I think it's useful for the preparation
of the tournament
right thank you very much
um I have no more questions for you
today so thank you very much everyone
and also the players tomorrow another
round will start at 3 P.M local time so
that's it for today thank you
[Applause]
ask me
ask me in a week is what Yan said about
long-term plans and long-term goals but
right now that is because it is only
this match that the two are thinking
about it is complete focus on winning
the World Championship and we had five
decisive games in the first half three
back-to-back draws in the second half
which means that Yan goes into the final
four games with five and a half points
he's two points away from being a crown
world champion he has a one point lead
and for ding fans that is Striking
Distance the finish line is inside the
width every game with every passing game
the urgency increases the pressure
increases and ding Bobby what does thing
need to do to get a win from here
I still think he will get some chances
in this match I don't think it's going
to be like today where it's uh some very
steady draws I think that we will see at
least at least one big chance for him
possibly more we could easily see more
than that but I don't know if they'll
necessarily come from the games where he
has the white pieces because from
Beyond's point of view with the white
pieces he still wants to press for a win
because it's not at that it's still not
that margin that he's going to shut down
with white if it was plus two I think he
might shut down with white but with plus
one he'll still go for for a big fight
and then could also get Chances with the
black pieces we saw that critical game
seven that thing lost he actually did
have very serious chances to get the
upper hand in that game with black so I
think ding will get some chances he just
needs to be ready to accept them when
they come not easier said than done of
course but that's at least something for
him to look forward to
yeah in fact our pre-game odds by our
chesscom stats team gave a Yan the odd
of 83 if game 10 ended in a draw 83 to
become world champion so still a big
favorite with four games left and what
you said Fabi I was gonna ask you this
question Robert that with the math
situation Yan leads with the point he
starts with the white pieces in game 11.
how much risk will he take to actually
close down the shutdown to shut down the
match a Yan win essentially means match
over he's world champion will he
continue to have a solid approach or
will he try to take his chances tomorrow
Robert
yeah I don't think he's gonna take huge
risks because in game nine for example
when he hit the white pieces he had the
upper hand without taking any risks out
of the opening and if dingly Wren plays
something solid they make a draw he
won't be too displeased about that let's
not forget that after the game tomorrow
there will be a rest day that will give
Yan a bit of extra time to prepare to
have the black pieces I agree with
Fabiano that Ding will get chances I
don't think that this match is over by
no stretch of the imagination is that
the case however I think that for
example if ding the ram were to play a
French Jan would choose a quite solid
line he's not going to allow any sort of
imbalances because at this stage with
just four games remaining every draw
inches him closer to that finish line
and that world champion title
and the action that we saw today just
how level the game was the accuracy that
was pointed out it just feels a very
stable part of the match like both
players are feeling extremely confident
neither of them are playing Super rash
you're not seeing the kind of Errors the
kind of inaccuracies that we saw in the
first half which would give another
player a chance and with five decisive
games in the first half three draws in
the second half Robert what do you think
is the reason for the match reaching
this momentum as we're seeing
well part of it is nerves I mean the
game 8 draw was not just this solid
Affair dingley run had a winning
position had he picked up that Rook he
would have escaped the Perpetual check
this match would have been tied after
eight games but in the last two games in
particular I think we've seen some maybe
a slight inaccuracy from dingly Wren
that Rook B8 move in game nine but
nothing drastic both players are playing
solid types of openings which don't
leave as much wiggle room uh to go wrong
so I think that uh for the players they
have stabilized I think Janda Palm she
has been quite impressive especially
today's preparation and for dingley red
he may need to play an objectively risky
move at some point to try to take the
match into unfamiliar territory for Yan
he said it himself ding was like I could
have retreated my Bishop but I thought
maybe it could was just bad for me and I
shouldn't do that but in order to win
games sometimes you have to risk losing
yeah well with just four games remaining
the urgency is here ding at some point
will have to go all out to create his
chances on the board Fabi he starts with
the black pieces tomorrow how important
is it for him to just have a risk-free
opening to get out of the opening we've
seen these amazing Surprises by him by
ding he's played the French here he
started with the Berlin and I'm going to
ask you are you expecting another solid
approach by being taking on the Berlin
one more time
I think we'll see another deviation and
I'm excited to see what that deviation
might be but we're already at the moment
when it's not a desperate situation if
ding draws it's not completely desperate
but he will want to to create the
possibility of chances that you know
something sharper happens that he plays
for a win so another opening besides
Berlin also I don't know if you really
want to
to play the Berlin and invite
preparation it seems like he's been
trying to jump around avoiding any
potential prep from from yon so I think
we might see that again I don't know if
it'll be a French I don't know if it'll
be something else maybe a night or I
actually think it would be a fascinating
choice to play the night or if at this
stage in the match but why not I mean
it's not like you have a world
championship match every day so take
your chances you're behind in the match
create create some chances I would say
it's definitely
a possible strategy although if he loses
I'll say
you know
I apologize for the bad advice
um but yeah you you don't know what the
right approach is maybe it's a good idea
to take some risks
you know that Ding has been following
the comment commentary a little bit
at this stage and of course with the
players it's going to be the big
question of how much risk each of them
wants to take does Napo want to keep
things solid with his approach with
white or will he try to create his
chances to shut down the match meanwhile
ding with only four games remaining will
he rely on his final two games with
white or will he want to create
something unexpected even with the black
pieces there is a big game 11 coming up
tomorrow before another rest day after
which then will return with the white
pieces it's been such a fantastic day of
Chess that we've had where both players
really held their whole own being
asserting at pressure on the board from
the start but never enough Yan's
defensive resources and just his ability
to be calm on the board and keeping a
control on the clock saw him cruise
through this game then test by white
from dingler in and we will be back with
the action from game 11 guys it's been
so much fun once more thank you so much
Fabi thank you so much Robert for
joining us and for breaking down the
action so that chat and I can stay up
with what these world-class players are
doing in Astana right now a big shout
out to our chat we're just being amazing
as always and we will be back with game
11 tomorrow for now we leave you with
all the big moments from today see you
tomorrow
we can expect dingley Ren to play
something new he has Richard report as
his second when you hire that man you
have to play variety because variety is
the spice of life and I think we are
going to get something new today I think
one C4 I think we're gonna see in
English and there it is it is 1c4 played
he was thinking about it or at least he
was trying to make us think he was
thinking about it this is very decent
for luck like here I don't think white
has any serious chances for an advantage
draw is a very likely result we did just
see F4 played I would not want to play
this from black I just don't really see
the proper defensive setup Jana is
playing this also super confident since
G5 not a single move has he thought for
more than like 10 seconds I think every
move has been just bashed out instantly
we've played Rook to A3 absolutely
forced otherwise I think black will lose
this game I don't think that they will
take too long to play this one out yeah
is going to be a draw and being there
with a smile gives it up he knows
there's no trying in this one yeah she
saves the game with the black pieces
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign